STUDENT SUCCESS WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR HEARING TODAY
IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY WE HAVE ONE
OTHER MEMBER PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY SENATOR RICHARD ROTH.
WE ALSO HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION THE
SORENSON IMPACT CENTER AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF UTAH AND THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IT IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE
PLEASE SELECT A NEW BEFORE YOU
BEGIN. SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS- ALLOW AND- WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 YOU CAN SEE IT ON
THE SCREN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SIX OH ONE ONE SIX THREE
FIVE. FOR DETAILEDINSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AND ARE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BE HEARING ALL THE PANELS
OF WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA
PRIOR TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. WHAT YOU'VE HEARD ALL
THE WITNESSES WILL HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO. COMMENT ON THE
TOPICS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST BE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
AND I DON'T EXPECT THAT MAYBE
REMOVED FROM THEIR PROMOTE
NEEDING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT A HEARING. IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MATTER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS. WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. OKAY SO
LET ME SAY AGAIN GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR JOINING
ME TODAY TO DISCUSS AN ISSUE
CENTRAL TO THE EXISTENCE OF OUR
SELECT COMMITTEE ON STUDENT
SUCCESS AND THAT IS HOW WELL WE
ARE DOING TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE
IN A TIMELY WAY. I WILL
INTRODUCE ALL THE WITNESSES FOR
DAYS TODAY'S HEARING IN A FEW
MINUTES BUT I DO WANT TO EXTEND
A SPECIAL WELCOME TO SENATOR
RICHARD ROTH. WHO HAS CHAIRED
THE BUDGET SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE ON EDUCATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US
TODAY FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SENATE ROTH. THE ISSUE OF ON
TIME COLLEGE GRADUATION HAS
ALWAYS BEEN IMPORTANT TO OUR
COMMITTEE BUT IT'S EVEN MORE SO
TODAY AS WE COPE WITH THE
PANDEMIC. A GLOBAL HEALTH
CRISIS THAT HAS AFFECTED
EVERYONE IN SO MANY WAYS. I
WANT TO FIRST OFFER MY-
THOUGHTS AND CONDOLENCES TO
EVERYONE WHO HAS BEEN
PERSONALLY AFFECTED BY COVERT
NINETEEN- WE- MOURN YOUR LOSSES
IN SOME CASES THE DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES SET THEIR
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES IN ALL
CASES. DEALING WITH THIS
DREADED DISEASE. OUR BATTLE TO
CREATE BETTER CONDITIONS FOR
COLLEGE STUDENT SUCCESS
PARTICULARLY AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS. HAS
BEEN ONGOING SINCE THIS
COMMITTEE WAS FORMED FOUR YEARS
AGO. OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST FEW YEARS THE CSU AND THE
LEGISLATURE I'M HAPPY TO SAY
HAVE PARTNERED TOGETHER TO
IMPROVE GRADUATION RATES. LET
ME GIVE YOU A BIT OF HISTORY IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE THE CSU BEGAN
WORKING ON CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP THAT ASK CAMPUS
IS TO INCREASE THEIR SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATES. AND AFTER
SEEN MANY IMPROVEMENTS AND I
GOT TO SEE THEM FIRST HAND AS A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES- AND AFTER
CONSULTATION WITH CAMPUSES IN
AND STAKEHOLDERS THE CHANCELLOR
ANNOUNCED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. THAT THE SYSTEM HAD
REVISED ITS GOALS AND LAUNCHED
A NEW GRADUATION INITIATIVE TO
NOW INCREASE FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES. 42% BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AT THAT TIME THE
CSU IS OVERALL FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE STOOD AT 19%
THE CSU IS ALSO MADE A
SIGNIFICANT BREAK IN A POLICY
THAT WASN'T WORKING IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ELIMINATED
NONCREDIT REMEDIAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS WHICH WAS BLOCKING THE
PATH OF STUDENT PROGRESS RATHER
THAN AIDING AT. THAT PROGRAM
WAS REPLACED BY CLASSES THE
KERRY CREDIT AND INCLUDE EXTRA
HOURS IN SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
WHO NEED THAT HELP WE OF COURSE
HAD A SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING ON THAT SUBJECT A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AS WELL. IN
A FEW MINUTES WE'LL HEAR FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FROM THEIR SYSTEM Y.
PERSPECTIVE WITH DOCTOR JAMES
MINOR I WILL ALSO HEAR FROM TWO
OF THEIR TOP LEADERS FROM THE
CAMP FROM A CAMPUS PERSPECTIVE
DR EDUARDO WOULD SHOW UP
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY MONTEREY BAY. AND DR
JOSE GOMEZ EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT AT CAL STATE LA.
AGAIN GOING BACK NOW TO A
LITTLE BIT OF MORE OF HISTORY.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AT MY
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM TO
CREATE A FOR YOUR PATHWAY FOR
LOW INCOME. FIRST GENERATION
AND UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS-
EIGHT PROVIDED A COMMITMENT AN
OPTIONAL COMMITMENT FOR
STUDENTS- EXCHANGE FOR. A
DETERMINATION TO GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS THEY WERE GIVEN
PRIORITY REGISTRATION- EXTRA
DEVISING AND OTHER ASSISTANCE.
IN THE THREE YEARS SINCE THAT
PROGRAM'S EXISTENCE EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX STUDENTS HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION TO DATE
THE LEGISLATURE IS ALLOCATED A
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE
CSU GRADUATION INITIATIVE. WITH
THIS CONTINUED THIS OF THE
SUPPORT THE CSU IS ADDED COURSE
SECTIONS AND FACULTY TO ENSURE
STUDENTS CAN TAKE THE COURSES
THEY NEED STEPPING UP ADVISING
AND EARLY INTERVENTIONS AND
INCREASING ACADEMIC FINANCIAL
AND OTHER SUPPORT. OUR
COLLABORATION. HAS LED TO A
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE FOR
FIRST TIME FRESHMEN THAT NOW
STANDS AT THIRTY ONE PERCENT.
UP SIGNIFICANTLY FROM 19% IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. ABOUT
HALFWAY TO THE SYSTEMS GOAL OF
REACHING 40% BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. ENCOURAGING FACT THAT'S
BEEN SHARED WITH ME RECENTLY IS
THAT. 85% OF FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN RETURNED THIS FALL FOR
A SECOND YEAR. THAT'S A VERY
ENCOURAGING SIGN AS WE LOOK
AHEAD. AND OF COURSE MANY OF
YOU ARE AWARE THAT THE OVERALL
ENROLLMENT AT THE CSU IS
NEARING FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND- WHICH IS AN ALL TIME
HIGH. TO GIVE CREDIT WHERE
CREDIT IS DUE CAMPUSES WITH THE
MOST IMPROVED FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES. ARE BASED ON.
NUMBERS THAT ARE ABOUT A YEAR
OLD OUR HOPING TO GET NEW ONES
BUT THE WHERE THERE'S BEEN THE
MOST IMPROVEMENT HAVE BEEN A
DOMINGUEZ HILLS SAN JOSE LONG
BEACH SACRAMENTO AND CSU LOS
ANGELES. BUT TO BE FAIR I MUST
ALSO MENTION CAMPUSES WITH THE
LEAST IMPROVE RATES OF THOSE
INCLUDE RIGHT IN MY BACKYARD-
CAL STATE EAST BAY. CHANNEL
ISLANDS BAKERSFIELD FRESNO AND
STANISLAUS SO THERE IS MORE
WORK TO BE DONE. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE ONLY ABOUT
THIRTEEN OF THE TWENTY THREE
CSU CAMPUSES HAVE A FOUR YEAR
PLEDGE PROGRAM. AND TWENTY ONE
CAMPUSES HAVE A TWO YEAR PLEDGE
PROGRAM- IN ADDITION ONLY SAN
JOSE STATE SACRAMENTO STATE AT
CSU LONG BEACH HAVE ROBUST
STUDENT ROMANS. IN THEIR
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM. SO
TO UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH MORE WE
NEED TO DO AND TAKE A LOOK AT-
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT STUDENT
EXPECTATIONS WHEN THEY- FIRST
ARRIVE ON CAMPUS ACCORDING TO
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE-
WHICH WE WILL HEAR FROM THIS
LATER THIS MORNING. NATIONALLY
ALMOST 90% OF FRESHMAN EXPECT
TO EARN A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
WITHIN FOUR YEARS. NINETY
PERCENT. WANT TO GET THROUGH IN%
FOUR YEARS. HOWEVER AT THE CSU
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
COMMITTEE TO GRADUATING IN FOUR
YEARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM AS LOW AS I AS
I MENTIONED. EVEN THOUGH IT'S
CLEAR THAT STUDENTS WANT TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM ZARA
WHO RIDE THAT. THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION ON THIS ISSUE. WE
KNOW THAT OUR CAMPUSES MUST DO
BETTER TO OUR REGION PUBLICIZED
THAT. THE PROGRAM TO ALLOW. SIX
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF GRADUATING
IN A TIMELY WAY. I WANT TO MAKE
A JUST A COUPLE FINAL POINTS
HERE BEFORE WE BEGIN THE
TESTIMONIES. IF WE'RE TO MEET
THE GOALS OF 40% OF FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THE CLASS OF STUDENTS
THAT ARE ARRIVING AT OUR
INSTITUTIONS NEXT FALL IS OUR
LAST CHANCE. TO MEET THAT THAT
GOAL- THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
COHORT THAT'S GOING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER WE HAVE
REACHED OUR GOAL IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THAT CLASSES COMING
IN LESS THAN TWELVE MONTHS FROM
TODAY. SO OUR ACTIONS IN THE
NEXT TWELVE MONTHS WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER WE CAN HIT
THAT 40% MARK. OF A 40%
GRADUATION RATE IN FOUR YEARS.
WELL FINALLY AT THE SAID THAT
THAT THAT WHILE THE CSU HAS
MADE STEADY PROGRESS IN THEIR
GRADUATION RATES THE SYSTEM HAS
ALSO MADE EFFORTS TO CLOSE THE
EQUITY GAP. FOR HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
THOSE WHO IDENTIFY AS AFRICAN
AMERICAN NATIVE AMERICAN OR
LATINO. HOWEVER THAT GAP HAS
BEEN VERY STUBBORN- THE FOUR
YEAR GAP BETWEEN AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND WHITE STUDENTS HAS
GROWN FROM 12% TO TWENTY SIX
PERCENT. AND THE WHITE LATINO
GAP HAS GROWN FROM 9% TO TWENTY
TWO PERCENT. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
THIS EQUITY GAP FROM OUR
PANELISTS PARTICULARLY CHECK
OBJECT JACKSON. FROM THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE. TODAY
STUDENTS ARE ENGAGED IN MORE
THAN EIGHTY THOUSAND VIRTUAL
COURSES AND- HAD ACCESS TO
ADVISEMENT HEALTH AND SUPPORT
SERVICES AS SHIFTED ONLINE. AND
WE KNOW UNDER KOVITZ- WITH HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT THAT THIS IS PUT A
LOT OF GRADUATION PATHWAYS AT
AT RISK. EARLIER THIS YEAR THE
EDUCATION TRUST RELEASED A POLL
THAT SHOWED THAT 75% OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT STAYING ON TRACK
TO GRADUATE BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS. WE'RE TO HEAR MORE
ON THIS SUBJECT FROM THREE HOT
NIGHT HERE FROM THE SOURCE AN
IMPACT. AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
RELATE TO WHY STUDENTS ARE
STRUGGLING THROUGH ONLINE
CLASSES AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
ALL THESE ISSUES THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY. TO HEAR FROM
EXPERTS TO HEAR FROM THE CSU.
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
STRATEGIES THAT THEY ARE
PUTTING IN PLACE ON THE SYSTEM
WIDE LEVEL ON THE CAMPUSES- TO
DEAL WITH THAT. THE CHALLENGES
THAT THAT WE ARE ALL FACING AND
STUDENT CERTAINLY STUDENTS ARE
FACING. BEFORE I INTRODUCE OUR
FIRST WITNESS I WANT TO INVITE
SENATOR ROB TO MAKE ANY REMARKS
BEFORE WE BEGIN TO APPRECIATE
HIS PARTNERSHIP ON THIS. SENATE
ROTH THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
ANY OPENING COMMENTS FROM YOU.
COMMENTS BUT I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE THIS IS A VERY VERY.
COURTNEIDGE YOU ARE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING WHAT
ANALYSTS HAVE TO SAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROCK I'D LOVE AND I'D
LIKE TO INVITE OUR FIRST
WITNESS DR JAMES MINOR HE IS
THE ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR.
AND SENIOR STRATEGIST- WHO WILL
PROVIDE A SYSTEM WIDE OVERVIEW
OF THE CSU GRADUATION
INITIATIVE- AND HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF THE BARRIERS CAMPUSES ARE
FACING TO MEET THAT TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE GOAL. DR MINOR IS A
NATIONAL EXPERT IN EXPANDING
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION AND
ADDRESSING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS- HE- PREVIOUSLY SERVED AT
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
IS HELD POSTS AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF GEORGIA MICHIGAN STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. DR
MINOR ORIGINALLY CAME FROM
DETROIT EARNED A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN SOCIOLOGY FROM
JACKSON STATE UNIVERSITY. A
MASTERS IN SOCIOLOGY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF NEBRASKA LINCOLN
AND A PHD IN EDUCATION POLICY
ANALYSIS AND LEADERSHIP. FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF WISCONSIN
MADISON DR MINOR IT'S GREAT TO
WELCOME YOU BACK TO OUR SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING AND WE
WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING SENATOR HI
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING- CENTER ROTH ALSO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES. PROGRESS
TOWARDS GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE GOALS
DESPITE WHAT YOU DESCRIBED AS
VERY CHALLENGING TIMES FOR US
ALL. WHEN I LAST SPOKE BEFORE
THIS- COMMITTEE. IT WAS IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR WE WERE
INSTEAD OF SACRAMENTO HERE ROOM
AND I BELIEVE SENATOR THAT WE
MAY NOT HAVE EVEN BEEN SIX FEET
APART. FROM EACH OTHER DURING
THAT TESTIMONY. AFTER THE
HEARING IN SACRAMENTO THE CSU
TEAM DEBRIEFED I TOOK A FLIGHT
BACK TO LONG BEACH AND WONDER
WHICH RESTAURANT WOULD BE THE
BEST CHOICE FOR DINNER.
NEEDLESS TO SAY SO MUCH HAS
CHANGED SINCE THE LAST TIME WE
SPOKE- THAT THE CRIME
CALIFORNIA WAS PROJECTING A SIX
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS. AND
TODAY AGRONOMISTS THE BUDGET
ANALYST ARE NOW TRYING TO
ACCURATELY ESTIMATE THE SIZE
AND SCALE OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET DEFICIT IN THE BILLIONS.
BACK IN FEBRUARY STATE SUPPORT
FOR THE C. ISSUE WAS STRONG. R.
AND THEN BY JUNE OUR SYSTEM SAW
A FOUR POINT 2% REDUCTION WHICH
EQUATED TO ROUGHLY THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- THAT
WERE REMOVED FROM OUR OPERATING
BUDGET. IN BACK IN FEBRUARY
THIS ISSUE ENROLLMENT AND
GRADUATION RATES WERE AT OR
NEAR ALL TIME HIGHS. NINE
MONTHS LATER I'M HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT EVEN AMIDST A
PUNISHING PANDEMICS THE ISSUE A
ROLE MANY GRADUATION NUMBERS
CONTINUE TO BE STRONG WITH THE
SPRING TWENTY TWENTY GRADUATION
RATES. BEST NUMBER FOUR THAT'S
THE ISSUE WHILE MANY
INSTITUTIONS NATIONWIDE
REPORTED A DECLINE IN
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT THE
TWENTY THREE CSU CAMPUSES
COLLECTIVELY AND ROLLED THEIR
LARGEST CLASS EVER IS YOU KNOW
IT. FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND PLUS STUDENTS MORE
THAN THREE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
MORE THAN THE PREVIOUS CALL
FOR. SO I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU JUST BRIEFLY A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS- IN TERMS OF OUR
PROGRESS ON THE GRADUATION.
IGNATIEV QUICKLY FIVE
GRADUATION. RATES BOB. FOUR
YEAR RATE AS YOU NOTICED
SENATOR NOW STANDS AT FORTY
MORE ARE 31% THIS IS A TWELVE
PERCENTAGE POINT INCREASE FROM
WHEN WE BEGAN THIS IS THE
HIGHEST RATE IN THE HISTORY FOR
THE C. ISSUE WHEN THEY BUILD ON
THE MOMENTUM THAT WE HAVE
GAINED OVER THE YEARS AND
REPRESENTS STEADY PROGRESS
TOWARDS OUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
GOAL OF FORTY PERCENT. ON ONE
ALSO MENTIONED THAT THE C.
ISSUE ALSO PRODUCED A HUNDRED
AND NINE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BACCALAUREATE DEGREES
THIS IS AN ADDITIONAL TWO
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE COMPARED TO THE PREVIOUS
YEAR. THE SIX YEAR GRADUATION
RATE IS NOW AT 62% WHICH IS ON
PAR WITH THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
FOR PUBLIC FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES. TWO YEAR TRANSFER
RATE SOMETHING THAT IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT TO US-
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
GRADUATING TWO YEARS AFTER
TRANSFERRING TO THE C. ISSUE
NOW STANDS AT FORTY FOUR
PERCENT. AGAIN THE HIGHEST EVER
FOR THE C. ISSUE IN JUST ONE
PERCENTAGE POINT AWAY. FROM OUR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE GOAL. THE
FOR YOUR TRAIN RATE OPERAR A
STUDENTS WHO COME TO THE CSU OR
GRADUATING- FOUR YEARS LATER IS
NOW 79% ALSO THE HIGHEST EVER.
AND AS YOU KNOW SENATOR BEFORE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE THE CSU
TRANSFER STUDENT COMPLETION
RATES WERE ALREADY AMONG THE
HIGHEST IN THE NATION. COMPARED
TO PEER INSTITUTIONS WITH
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
STRATEGIC FOCUS CAMPUSES HAVE
ENHANCED THEIR SUPPORT OF
TRANSFER STUDENTS FURTHER
AUGMENTING THEIR SUCCESS.
ANOTHER NOTABLE MILESTONE AS
YOU MENTIONED- WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY RELEVANT GIVEN THE
PANDEMIC IS A C. ISSUE POSTED
ITS HIGHEST EVER RETENTION RATE
AT EIGHTY FIVE AND A HALF
PERCENT. FOR FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS WERE RETURNING FOR
THEIR SECOND TERM. WELL AS YOU
KNOW AND YOU HAD MENTIONED- THE
C. ISSUE IS ONLY ONE OF A
HANDFUL OF INSTITUTIONS
NATIONWIDE. THAT IS PUBLICLY
DECLARED THE GOAL OF NOT
CLOSING BUT ELIMINATING EQUITY
GAPS. THAT WOULD CELEBRATE THE
GAME THAT WE AVE MADE IN
GRADUATION RATES WE ALSO NOW.
THAT OUR SUCCESS IS NOT TRULY
COMPLETE AND LOTS OF REPRESENTS
SUCCESS FOR ALL STUDENTS
INCLUDING OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
WHAT THE SAME INTENSE FOCUS WE
HAVE PLACED ON MOVING THE
NEEDLE ON GRADUATION RATES WE
MUST NOW RENEW OUR COMMITMENT
TO ELIMINATING EQUITY GAPS THAT
EXIST TODAY. THIS YEAR WE CAN
REPORT THAT THE GAP IN
GRADUATION RATES BETWEEN PELL
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AND THEIR
PEERS IS NINE POINT 2% THE GAP
CLOSED BY ONE PERCENTAGE POINT
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR. FOR
STUDENTS WHO IDENTIFY AS
AFRICAN AMERICAN NATIVE
AMERICAN OR LATIN ACTS WE ALSO
SAW THE EQUITY GP NARAL
BETWEEN THE STUDENTS AND THEIR
PEERS FROM ELEVEN POINT ONE
PERCENTAGE POINTS LAST YEAR TO
TEN POINT FIVE PERCENTAGE
POINTS THIS YEAR. THESE NUMBERS
WALL ALTHOUGH INCREMENTAL
REPRESENT FAR FOUGHT
IMPROVEMENTS FROM LAST YEAR AND
REFLECT OUR ONGOING COMMITMENT
TO STUDENTS ARE TO ELIMINATE
EQUITY GAPS DRIVEN BY A BETTER
AND MORE SOPHISTICATED DATA AN
EQUITY DRIVEN POLICIES. WHAT IS
THE ISSUE IS ACCOMPLISHED OVER
THE PAST FIVE YEARS AS
RIGHTFULLY GAIN LOCAL AND
NATIONAL ATTENTION IT IT IS
TRULY EXTRAORDINARY CHANGE FOR
SUCH A LARGE AND COMPLEX
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. HOWEVER WE
ARE CLEAR THAT THERE IS MORE
WORK YET TO BE DONE. WE'RE AT
THE HALFWAY MARK AND SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WILL REQUIRE ONGOING
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE. IT
WILL REQUIRE EVEN MORE
INNOVATION ON OUR CAMPUSES AND
THE KIND OF INSTITUTIONAL
DEXTERITY DEMONSTRATED THIS
PAST YEAR TO ENSURE THAT THE
ISSUE STUDENTS CONTINUE. TO BE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
HIGH QUALITY AFFORDABLE DEGREES.
NOW I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN WE
LAUNCH THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE- WE KNEW AT THE TIME
THAT OUR PROGRESS BETWEEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WOULD NOT BE
PERFECTLY LINEAR. HOWEVER I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT NO ONE WAS
THINKING GLOBAL PANDEMIC IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WE'RE AT THE HALFWAY
MARK. I DO WANNA TAKE A MOMENT
TO HIGHLIGHT JUST A FEW OF THE
LARGE SCALE PROHIBITS THAT WE
HAVE EXECUTED OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS TO ENSURE THAT
WE PRESERVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
OUR STUDENTS. AS YOU MENTIONED
IN TOTAL MORE THAN SEVENTY
THOUSAND COURSES WERE
TRANSITION TO VIRTUAL DELIVERY
PRESERVING ACADEMIC CONTINUITY
IN PROGRESS 2 DEGREES FOR MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS. MORE THAN
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND FACULTY
MEMBERS PARTICIPATED IN NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
HOURS OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OVER THE SUMMER TO
SUPPORT MORE EFFECTIVE VIRTUAL
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS FOR OUR
STUDENTS. AND WITH AN AWARENESS
OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS. OUR CSU CAMPUSES HAVE
DISTRIBUTED MORE THAN TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND NEW LAPTOPS AND
TABLETS AND OFFER MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND BOB WIFI HOT SPOTS. AN
INVESTMENT OF MORE THAN
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS THIS
IS IN ADDITION TO THE THOUSANDS
OF LAPTOPS AND TABLETS ALREADY.
ON HAND AT OUR CAMPUSES THAT
WERE MADE AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS. WITH THE ISSUE RANGE
OF ACADEMIC AND SUPPORT
SERVICES WERE ALSO CONVERTED TO
VIRTUAL MODALITIES INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO STUDENT
ADVISING DISABILITY SERVICES
SUPPLEMENTAL LEARNING SUPPORT
FINANCIAL LATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. AND OUR BASIC NEEDS
INITIATIVES AND ALSO ALL THE I.
T. SUPPORT THAT WE'RE NOW
PROVIDING TO STUDENTS IS DONE
PRIMARILY VIRTUAL. ALL OF THESE
ARE EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS
SCAFFOLD ID THE PROGRESS FOR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. DIFFERENT WHAT IT
UNDOUBTEDLY HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGING EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR AND OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM MA'AM FOR THE
NATION. SINCE THESE
DEVELOPMENTS ARE LARGE SCALE-
THEY'RE EMBEDDED. IN THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE AND IT A
FUNDAMENTALLY RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO DO THINGS AT SCALE BUT
ALSO THE IMPORTANCE OF
LOCALIZED OF SOME OF THOSE
EFFORTS. AND THE NEED TO
ACCOUNT FOR VARIATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA STUDENT DEMOGRAPHICS.
AND OUR CAMPUS NEEDS. WITH THAT
SAME THERE SO AFFECTED PRACTICE
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED ALMOST
UNIVERSAL ADOPTION SO I WANT TO
TALK AGAIN AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL
CAMPUSES WHAT THE HAVE
CUSTOMIZED THEIR EFFORTS BUT
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING AT SCALE
SYSTEM Y. ONE. I JUST WANT TO
MENTION HERE THE BASIC NEEDS
INITIATIVE OUR SYSTEM WIDE
EFFORT TO HOLISTICALLY ADDRESS
STUDENTS WELL BEING BOTH INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM.
FROM HOUSING AND FOOD AND
SECURITY WE'RE NOW HAVE MONTH
MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
COORDINATED EFFORTS TO PROVIDE.
BASIC FOOD AND HOUSING SUPPORT
FOR OUR STUDENTS WHICH NOW
INCLUDE- DRIVE UP. IN SECURITY
SUPPORT FOR MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ACROSS OUR CAMPUSES
YOU WILL HEAR MORE FROM OUR
CAMPUS LEADERS ON THIS PANEL
ABOUT THE INNOVATIVE ACADEMIC
ADVISING- BUT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE INFERENCES THAT
WE ARE PLACING ON PROVIDING
STUDENTS BETTER INFORMATION AND
GUIDANCE. AS THEY NAVIGATE
THEIR COLLEGE CAREERS. AND THEN
FINALLY- SENATOR I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE PROGRESS THAT
WE HAVE MADE AND THE WORK WE
HAVE YET TO DO ON THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT PROGRAM.
SINCE THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ACADEMIC YEAR
ALMOST NINETEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM WHAT THE 24% INCREASE
FROM LAST YEAR TO THIS YEAR. WE
SEE THIS IS ONE OF MANY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS THAT THE C.
ISSUE HAS THAT AT ITS DISPOSAL
ALONG WITH ADDITIONAL EFFORTS
TAILORED. TO SUIT LOCAL
DEMOGRAPHIC IN CAMPUS NEEDS
UNDER THE SIX OPERATIONAL
PRIORITIES OUTLINED. IN THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE. ALSO ONE
OF JUST BRIEFLY AND- WITH THE
CALLER FROM FROM- IMPORTANT
TICKET WE HAVE SEEN AND THE
AVERAGE STUDENT LOAD IN TERMS
OF THE COURSE TAKING PATTERNS
AND BEHAVIOR- WHICH HAS BEEN-
COMPLEMENTED BY OUR ABILITY TO
IMPROVE OUR COURSE OFFERING
CAPACITY. SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR SO MUCH OF A
ABOUT- FOR MUCH OF WHAT IS
IMPORTANT ABOUT IMPROVING THE
AVERAGE STUDENT UNIT LOW. IS
OUR CAMPUS CAPACITY INABILITY
TO DELIVER ADDITIONAL COURSE
SECTIONS. FOR MY BROTHER TODAY
IS NOT SEEKING TO GO INTO
CAMPUS BASED PACIFIC TIME ON
ALL OUR CAMPUS LEADERS TO DO
THAT. I JUST WANT TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRESS
THAT WE ARE MAKING TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY STUDENT HAS THE
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT.
NECESSARY TO OBTAIN A HIGH
QUALITY AFFORDABLE DEGREE WE
WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT LIE AHEAD AND
TO ASK FOR THE ONGOING SUPPORT
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO MAINTAIN
OUR UPWARD TRAJECTORY- IN
PRODUCING C. ISSUE DEGREE
HOLDERS. FOR SO MANY DEVELOPING
CALIFORNIANS SENATOR I NOW WANT
TO TURN THE PANEL OVER TO THE
PRESIDENT OF CSU MONTEREY BAY
EDUARDO OF CHIRLA TO PROVIDE A
CAMPUS VIEW OF. OUR STUDENT
SUCCESS EFFORTS. WITH THAT YOU
DOUG MINOR- I DID HOWE SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS BUT I'M
HAPPY GO AND HEAR FROM OUR
CAMPUS LEADERS FIRST AND THAT
THAT WE CAN START LOOPBACK.
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU BUT SO
FIRST LET ME ADD TO SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT DR ED CHAU IT'S
NICE TO SEE HIM AGAIN. HE HAS A
RICH PERSONAL HISTORY GREW UP
IN ARGENTINA BEFORE MOVING TO
PORTLAND OREGON IN HIGH SCHOOL
WENT ON TO EARN DEGREES IN
PHYSICS. NUCLEAR SCIENCE AND
ECONOMICS TO RE COLLEGE
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY AND THE NEW
SCHOOL FOR SOCIAL. RESEARCH DR-
CHOSE WORKED AS AN ENGINEER A
FACULTY MEMBER- AN ACADEMIC
ADMINISTRATOR HE WAS ASSISTANT
SECRETARY FOR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION- AND THEN HE OF
COURSE IS SERVED AS PRESIDENT A
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY MONTEREY
BAY SINCE TWO THOUSAND.
THIRTEEN SO IT'S A- IT'S A
WONDERFUL PLEASURE TO WELCOME
HIM BACK AND WE WELCOME YOUR
TESTIMONY NOW. THANK YOU CENTER
GRAY'S. GLAZER AND- THANK YOU
SIR ROBERT. THIS PRESENTATION
AS WELL- I'D LIKE TO SHARE
SOME. INFORMATION ABOUT OUR
CAMPUS. AND I DO HAVE A POWER
POINT. THAT I'M GOING TO SHARE
WITH YOU. IN A SECOND BUT I DID
WANT TO MAKE IT SOME GENERAL
OBSERVATIONS BEFORE I BEGAN-
CLEARLY AS AS- BUT OR MINOR
MENTION- COOPER HAS A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE CSU
AND- WE ARE REALLY PROUD OF THE
FACT THAT- LED BY OUR CHANCE
THROUGH OUR SYSTEM AND MADE AN
EARLY DECISION TO GO VIRTUAL.
FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE AND-
EXERCISE NATIONAL NATIONAL
LEADERSHIP IN DOING SO AND-
EVIDENCE OF PRUDENCE- RIGHT NOW
WE ARE NOW ALSO MAKING IT WITH
MEN NEVER DECISION TO CONTINUE
IN A VIRTUAL MODE- NOT ONLY IN
THE FALL BUT IN THE SPRING I
THINKTHAT WILL DOVETAIL NICELY
WITH SOME POSITIVE DEVELOPMENTS
IN THE VACCINE FRONT THAT MORE
I'M SURE WE'RE ALL AWARE OF.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
THIS PANDEMIC IS- THAT IS
AFFECTING THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY IS REALLY KIND OF
UNPREDICTABLE- THERE WAS AN
EXPECTATION- IN SACRAMENTO
THAT- THIS WOULD LEAD TO A
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT AND IN FACT IT APPEARS
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE. A
CONSERVATIVE LESS THAN THAT. S.
RET TODAY THAT THE- THEIR
DISSIPATING SICK. ONE TIME
SURPLUS. OF FOR THIS THIS
COMING YEAR BECAUSE REVENUES
ARE COMING IN HIGHER THAN
EXPECTED. OF COURSE THAT WOULD
BE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SOME INVESTMENTS. IN THIS ISSUE
AND GRADUATION INITIATIVE. BUT-
IT HAS TO BE POINTED OUT THAT
THE RECESSION HAS IMPACTED LOW
INCOME. AND LOW SKILL WORKERS
SO THE HARDEST- AND- THE BUT
THE ECONOMY HAS NOT SUFFERED AS
MUCH- PARTLY BECAUSE OF THE
CREATIVE USE OF TECHNOLOGY LIKE
WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW- AND THE
FACT THAT MANY OF OUR- HIGH
PAYING. SKILLED JOBS. CONTINUE
TO BE- HI CAN COULD DO TO BE
PERFORMED- WITH THIS
TECHNOLOGY. CLEARLY THE ECONOMY
WILL BE TRANSFORMED. ADAM
BECAUSE THIS THIS PANDEMIC HAS
ACCELERATED A LOT OF CHANGES
THAT WERE FORESEEABLE IN TERMS
OF THE USE OF TECHNOLOGY IN NEW
WAYS OF DOING THINGS. WHAT'S
CLEAR- THAT WILL BE THE CASE IN
THE POST FUND DEMING FUTURE. IS
THAT- FLEXIBLE SKILLS AND
TECHNOLOGICAL LITERACY WILL BE
PARAMOUNT- IN THE FUTURE AND
THAT A COLLEGE EDUCATION WILL
BE. EVEN MORE CRITICAL- TO
MAINTAIN THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIES PRODUCTIVITY AND THE
WELFARE OF OUR CITIZENS. SO I'M
MAKE THOSE POINTS LET ME JUST-
TURN NOW TO MY- POWERPOINT
PRESENTATION HERE. SO I'M GONNA.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE HAS BEEN
UNFOLDING AT OUR CAMPUS. IN A
NUTSHELL THIS IS- THESE ARE THE
RESULTS THE MOST CURRENT ONES-
THE TARGETS SET OUT ON THE
SECOND COLUMN AS YOU CAN SEE
THERE FOR- FOR YOUR TRANSFER-
AND- TO YOUR TRANSFER ETIENNE'S
46% RESPECTIVELY. AND OUR
CAMPUS HAS BEEN- REALLY
SUCCESSFUL AND- MEETING THOSE
OR EXCEEDING THEM ALREADY- EVEN
FIVE YEARS AWAY FROM THE
DEADLINE OF GI TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE- IT DOES SEEM THAT
GENERALLY SPEAKING- THIS ISSUE
HAS BEEN- EXCEEDING
EXPECTATIONS ON THE TRANSFER-
TARGETS. OVERALL AND- THERE'S
SOME REASONS FOR THAT THAT OLD
LIEU TO LATER- ON THE- SIX
YEAR- GRADUATION RATE FOR FIRST
TIME FRESHMEN. WE'RE MAKING
GOOD PROGRESS TOWARD OUR GOAL
OF 63% AND THE FOUR YEAR- WERE
A LITTLE BIT FARTHER AWAY- THE
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE BUT
BUT ALSO- IT LOOKS- WE THAT WE
ARE ON TRACK IF YOU ACTUALLY DO
THE- QUALITY OF THESE- IT WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE IT BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. L. ADD AND
THE UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
EQUITY GAPS. ARE AN INTERESTING
SITUATION THEY'RE NOT VERY
LARGE- IT FLUCTUATED- OVER THE-
FOUR YEARS WITH NO CLEAR TREND.
ON AVERAGE THE PELLEGRI YEP
IT'S BEEN ABOUT ONE PERCENT-
WITH OUR GOAL IS OF COURSE TO
ELIMINATED AND THEIR- UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY EQUITY
GAP. CURRENTLY STANDS AT- HALF
A PERCENT. IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION SO RIGHT NOW ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS ARE PERFORMING
SLIGHTLY BETTER THAN THE-
POPULATION AT LARGE BUT OF
COURSE THAT'S PROBABLY NOT
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT AS AS
A VERY SMALL DIFFERENCE. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE OBSERVED IS
THAT- SYSTEM BE USED TO HAVE-
NO GAPS WHATSOEVER- WHEN WE
STARTED IN THE DOWN THIS ROAD
OF THE G. I.'S TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THAT WAS A GOOD NEWS THAT
THE BAD NEWS WAS THAT THE
REASON WAS THAT THE VIRUS FROM
RACE WERE NOT TERRIBLY GOOD FOR
ANYBODY. AND SO AS WE'VE MADE
GOOD PROGRESS- ON THESE-
GRADUATION RATES- THE- THOSE
RATES HAVE ALSO INCREASED-
INCREASE FOR PL AND YOU ARE AND
STUDENTS- BUT IN THE CASE OF
FELT SON OF A GAP STARTED TO
EMERGE- SO THAT THE IMPROVEMENT
OVERALL WAS A LITTLE BIT LARGER
THAN THE IMPROVEMENT WITHIN.
THE PAL STUDENT POPULATION FOR
THAT SO THEY THEY GAP STARTED
TO EMERGE IS NOT VERY LARGE
DOESN'T CLEAR TREND BUT IT IS
THERE AND WHAT IS SUGGESTED TO
US IS THAT WE MAY NEED TO-
HAVING PICKED THE LOW HANGING
FRUIT FOR THE POPULATION OF
STUDENTS AT LARGE. WE MAY NEED
SOME TARGETED- SO- CAL STUDENTS
AND FOR UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITIES. HI THIS IS HOW WE
ACHIEVE THESE RESULTS
UNNATURAL- THE OVERSIGHT IS FOR
ADVISING COMMANDERS
MINIATURIZATION OUR- DEAL TURNS
WE DEVELOPED TO REMEDIATION
RESPONSE TO AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
ELEVEN TEN- THE AUTO MODEL
WHICH IS OUR- RESPONSE TO
EXECUTIVE ORDER ELEVEN HUNDRED
CALLING FOR A REVAMPING OF
GENERAL EDUCATION. A
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE TWEAKS IN OUR
PROCEDURES- RENEWED FOCUS ON
TRANSFER STUDENTS ARE PAYING
ATTENTION TO BASIC NEEDS AND-
FOCUSING ON INCREASED STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT THAT'S THE OVER HERE
LET ME GO THROUGH THESE POINTS
ON A LITTLE MORE DETAIL.
ADVISING WHAT WE'VE DONE THERE
IS WE HAVE CENTRALIZED- THE
ADVISORS AND CONNECTED THEM TO
THE CAREER SERVICES CENTER- AND
REALLY MADE IT MORE OF A
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO ADVISING
STUDENTS SO THEY'RE CLEAR ON
THEIR PATHWAYS. WE'VE ALSO
INCREASE THE OVERALL NUMBER OF
ADVISORS. THERE IS AN EARLY
ALERT TEAM AND THAT- DOES
OUTREACH TO AT RISK STUDENTS
THEN THAT'S A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM OF FACULTY
ADVISORS TUTORS. AND STUDENT
FARES- PROFESSIONALS THAT-
SPOT- YOU KNOW EMERGING
PROBLEMS WITH STUDENTS AND- AND
INTERVENE. I WE- APPROACH A
HUNDRED NICE IN FALL TWENTY
UNDER THIS PROGRAM. MANDATORY
ORIENTATION WE- THIS HAS LED TO
WE NOW REQUIRE EVERY STUDENTS
COMING. I DON'T TEND ORANGE
ASIAN AND THAT HAS REALLY LED
TO- IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES-
THE OVERALL ENROLLMENT RATE HAS
INCREASED- FOR STUDENTS AS WELL
AS FOR- UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS- THE STUDENTS WHO
DO ATTEND MANAGER EDITION ARE
SHOWING HIGHER PARTICIPATION IN
CO CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES- IN
ACADEMIC ADVISING. AND IN FIRST
SECOND TERM RETENTION. AS WELL
AS IN MAINTENANCE OF GOOD
ACADEMIC STANDING SO THESE ARE
ALL MEASURABLE OUTCOMES- THAT
SHOW IMPROVEMENT AS A RESULT
THIS MANCHURIAN TATIAN-
EXECUTIVE ORDER ELEVEN TEN- THE
WAY WE RESPONDED TO THAT OUR
CAMPUSES WE DEVELOPED A
STRAIGHT STRETCH CORE STRATEGY
FOR ENGLISH- REMEDIATION- THE
TWO SEMESTER COURSE FOR WRITTEN
COMMUNICATION WAS DEVELOPED BY
DOCTOR GRAPH- EVEN BEFORE YOUR
ELEVEN HUNDRED ELEVEN TEN CAME
INTO PLAY BUT ONCE IT DID WE-
EXTENDED- THE COVERAGE OF THAT
COURSE TO STUDENTS THAT WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE. A TAKEN A
REMEDIAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
COURSES AND THE OUTCOMES HAVE
BEEN REALLY QUITE POSITIVE-
WHEN INITIALLY IS- INTRODUCED
THIS COURSE REDUCED- D. D. W.
OR F. GRADES OF STUDENTS FROM
THIRTEEN POINT THREE OF SIX
POINT SEVEN AND AFTER WE
EXPANDED THE COVERAGEOF THIS
COURSE TO STUDENTS WHO WOULD
HAVE NORMALLY BEEN GOING
THROUGH DEVELOPMENTAL COURSES-
THIS PROPORTION REMAINED AT SIX
POINT 7% FOR THE STUDENTS THAT
WE ADDED THAT WOULD HAVE%
NORMALLY TAKEN DRAMA COURSES
WERE JUST AS SUCCESSFUL- WITH
THIS NEW STRETCH COURSE
APPROACH AS- POPULATION. OF
STUDENTS OF LARGE. AUG FOR MATH
THE APPROACH HAS BEEN TO DO
CORE. SUPPORT OF TO AND
ASSISTANCE. AND THE COURSES
HAVE BEEN REDUCED TO THREE
UNITS TO MATCH THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS AND SUPPLEMENTED
WITH SUPPORT SERVICES IN THE
PAST RATES HAVE IMPROVED. HE
GOT TO SPEND REDUCE. YOUR
LIVING HUNDREDS CALLING FOR THE
REVAMP OF- GENERAL EDUCATION-
RESPONSE WAS THE AUTHOR MODEL.
WHICH ALLOWED FOR EASIER
TRANSFER FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BETTER ARTICULATION OF
THOSE GENERAL EDUCATION
COURSES- AND DECREASE TIME
GRADUATION. IT SUPPLEMENTAL
EXTRA INSTRUCTION WE FOCUS ON
STEM COURSES. WE RECEIVED- A
AYE NATURE'S AYE GRANT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
SUPPORTS THIRTY FIVE TUTORS AND
THREE INSTRUCTIONAL ASSISTANCE
AND THIS HAS LED TO IMPROVE
PASS RATES IN THE SCHOOL. AND
REDUCE EQUITY GAPS IN NOW
GATEWAY COURSES IN CHEMISTRY.
SOME ADMINISTRATIVE TWEAKS THAT
WE'VE DONE- WE HAVE INSTITUTED
WALKING ROMAN FORSTA AND
SEVERAL STUDENTS SUPPORT
PROGRAM SO STUDENTS THAT TAKE.
UP PROGRAM THE PARTICIPATING
CAMPUS WILL- NSCS AND THREE
WHICH IS A COMPUTER SCIENCE- IN
THREE PROGRAM AIMED AT THE- US
STUDENTS FROM THE- UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IN SALINAS VALLEY.
AND THE LIVING LEARNING
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ESTABLISH
FOR OUR STUDENTS- THESE ALL NOW
ARE- HANDLE THROUGH WALKING TO-
THE- THAT AND THAT LEADS TO
IMPROVED OUTCOMES WELL- WE- WE
DO- MORE PRO ACTIVE I REACH ON
HOLES WHEN STUDENTS ARE PLACED
ON A REGISTRATION HOLD BECAUSE-
THEY HAVE TOO MANY- CREDITS
THEIR SUPERCENTERS OR WHETHER
THEY ARE- I'M MISSING AN
IMMUNIZATION OR THEIR OWN
OPERATION. WOULD PUT THEM ON
HOLD WE REQUIRE THEM TO COME IN
AND GET ADVISING AND THAT HELPS
ALSO- KEEP GOOD TIMELY PASSED
TO GRADUATION- AND FOR-
STUDENTS THAT- THAT HAVE-
STOPPED OUT AND ARE CLOSE TO
GRADUATING WE HAVE DONE SOME-
PROACTIVE I REACH THEM AND
ENCOURAGE THEM TO ENROLL AND
FINISH THEIR DEGREE HOW AND SO
THAT ALSO HAS LED TO SOME. SOME
IMPROVEMENTS. THE TRANSFER
STUDENTS SAID I THINK THAT AND
THIS IS WHERE I WENT OVER
HARPER- CIRCLE BACK TO THE
EARLY RESERVATION THAT WE SEEM
TO HAVE EXCEEDED THE TARGETS
FOR THEM- GRADUATION INITIATIVE
ON TRANSFER GRADUATION RATES
AND THAT THIS IS NOT UNUSUAL IN
THIS ISSUE AND I THINK. A LOT
OF IT HAS TO DO WITH SOME OF
THESE FACTORS THE FACT THAT-
THE SUBSIDY REFER TRANSFER I
THINK IS REALLY- HELPED. A
FOCUS ON- AND REALLY- MAKING
SURE THAT OUR ARTICULATION AND
TRANSFER CREDIT RULES WITH OUR-
FEEDER COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
ARE OURS ARE SEAMLESS. THE USE
OF THE OASIS DEGREE AUDIT AND
DEGREE PLANNER TOOLS FOR
STUDENTS- THOSE ARE REALLY
HELPFUL. WE HAVE A TRANSFER ST
NOW THAT HAS A FULL TIME
COORDINATOR AND TRY PEER
MENTORS ASSIST TRANSFER
STUDENTS. WE HAVE A WELCOME DAY
JUST FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS- AND
THE- TRANSFER ORIENTATION
REALLY- IS EXTENDED NOW TO
FIFTEEN WEEKS IN THE FALL AND
SIX IN THE SPRING. AND THEN THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE HAVE A DEAL OF SOME
CAREER PATHWAYS AGREEMENTS WITH
OUR FUTURE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN OUR AREA. AND THAT HAS ALSO.
I THINK LEAD TO IMPROVED
OUTCOMES AND THAT I GREATER
RATE OF TRANSFER FROM. OUR
FEEDER SCHOOLS HELPING THEM
ALSO BUT SHE ONE OF THEIR
OBJECTIVES WHICH IS THAT
STUDENTS WHO ENROLL IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH THE
INTENTION OF TRANSFERRING
SHOULD GO AHEAD AND DO SO AT A
HIGHER RATE THAN THEY HAVE IN
THE PAST. IN THE BASIC NEEDS-
WE HAVE- HELP STUDENTS WITH
EMERGENCY HOUSING NEEDS WITH
FOOD SECURITY. WITH UNEXPECTED
EXPENSES AND CHILD CARE WE HAVE
A- FULL TIME CARE MANAGER AND
BASIC NEEDS COORDINATOR. WE
RECEIVED A GRANT FROM A. T. AND
T. FOR GROCERY CARDS FOR
STUDENTS WITH FOOD SECURITY. WE
HAVE A SMALL GRANT PROGRAM FOR
UNEXPECTED EXPENSES FOR
STUDENTS- AND THE CALFRESH IS
ANOTHER GRANT PROGRAM THAT.
HELPS STUDENTS FOR WITHOUT FOOD
SECURITY. IT'S AN INCREASE TO
ENGAGE- WE- AND SPRING BREAK
LEADERSHIP PROGRAM- TO KEEP
STUDENTS ENGAGED WE HAVE- I
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR AND MEN OF
COLOR LINES PROGRAM TO. AND
MAKE THE- PARTICULARLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS WHO ARE A
SMALL GROUP WITHIN OUR CAMPUS-
MANY OF THEM COMING FROM-
COMMUNITIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE. HIGHLY
SEGREGATED AND HAVE NEVER
EXPERIENCED BEING ASMALL
MINORITY AND A AND A LARGE
CAMPUS HELPING THEM STAY
CONNECTED I'M FEELING GAUGE
WITH THE CAMPUS OF THE BLACK
STUDENT SUCCESS CENTER IS ALSO
HELPING WITH THAT. AND WE HAVE
THE AUTO CROSS CULTURAL CENTER
WHICH IS- ETCETERA THAT-
REALLY- IT HELPS STUDENTS
EXPAND THEIR HORIZONS AS WELL
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO MAKE
STUDENTS FEEL THAT THEY'RE PART
OF A COMMUNITY OF- OF SIMILAR
US. AS STUDENTS WITH SIMILAR
YOU KNOW WITH SAME IDENTITY BUT
ALSO REACH OUT AND CONNECT WITH
OTHERS- THAT'S ALSO PART OF THE
STUDENT EXPERIENCE. AND THE- Q.
UNDER HIS SUCCESS CENTER IS
THIS- ARE THE CENTER THAT HELPS
US TO UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS-
WITH THEIR UNIQUE CHALLENGES SO
THESE ARE SOME OF THE- MEASURES
AND TACTICS THAT WE'VE WE'VE
USED TO ACHIEVE THE RESULTS
THAT WE HAVE. AND ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES- IN IN. REAL LIFE-
SUCH LIKE THIS IS THE IS NOT A-
LIKE- HEY THIS IS NOT A DOUBLE
BLIND- CONTROL- EXPERIMENT-
THIS IS MORE LIKE AN
ENGINEERING LAB DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS WHERE YOU JUST KEEP
TRYING THINGS TO IMPROVE
PERFORMANCE. AND WHEN YOU TRY
MULTIPLE THINGS IN THE OVERALL
PERFORMANCE IMPROVES. IT'S VERY
TOUGH TO FIGURE OUT WHICH ONE
OF THESE THINGS IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR HOW MUCH OF THE
IMPROVEMENT. BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT- AS A WHOLE THE THIS
CLUSTER OF- TACTICS HAS LED TO-
THE RESULTS THAT WE HAVE
ACHIEVE OF WHICH WERE. VERY
WHAT THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION AND CENTER LASER
THAT THANK YOU PRESIDENTIAL-
AND THAT IS A GREAT TOOL BOX
OF- OF USEFUL THINGS THAT YOU
WERE DOING ON THE CAMPUS IT'S
VERY IMPRESSIVE- TO SEE. I KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM OUR
FRIENDS AT CAL STATE LA IN JUST
A MOMENT BUT CAN I JUST ASK ONE
QUESTION FOR THE MOMENT AT
LEAST IN THAT SET. WHAT WHAT
ARE YOU DOING ON THE CAMPUS TO
MAKE STUDENTS AWARE OF THE FOR
YOUR PATH PROGRAM THAT WOULD
GIVE THEM PRIORITY REGISTRATION
AND GET THEM. TO COMMIT TO
TRYING TO ACHIEVE THAT FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION WHAT WHAT WHAT
YOU DO TO PUBLICIZE THAT ON
YOUR CAMPUS. WELL THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS- SHARE WITH
STUDENTS AS PART OF THE OVERALL
ADVISING AND ORIENTATION
PROGRAMS. AND I CAN REPORT
THAT- LAST YEAR. WE HAD NINETY
SIX STUDENTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE AND ALL OF THEM I
GRADUATED. WITHIN TWO YEARS-
AND CURRENTLY WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE NEW AND
CONTINUING STUDENTS THIS YEAR
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING. IT'S
GREAT TO HEAR AND- I DO NOTICES
WE TRAVEL AROUND TO DIFFERENT
CAMPUSES AND TALK TO STUDENT
LEADERS- THAT IN SOME CAMPUSES
THEY'RE JUST NOT EVEN AWARE OF
THAT PATHWAY AND THAT THE
OPPORTUNITIES IT PROVIDES TO
THEM AND I APPRECIATE. HEARING
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING ON YOUR
CAMPUS WELL LET ME TURN NOW TO
INTRODUCE DR JOSE GOMEZ. HE IS
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY LOS
ANGELES I KNOW A KEY PARTNER
WITH PRESIDENT COVINO- IN THEIR
EFFORT TO AND ACHIEVE STUDENT
SUCCESS- WHICH SAID DR GOMEZ
HAS BEEN A LEADER ON. BEFORE
YOU CAME TO CAL STATE LOS
ANGELES IN TWO THOUSAND NINE HE
HELD SENIOR POSITIONS- IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE. I
SERVED AS THE CHIEF HIGHER
EDUCATION ADVISER TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. DR GOMEZ GOT HIS
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN SOCIOLOGY
FROM CAL POLY POMONA. A
MASTER'S DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION AND HIS PHD IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE WELCOME-
DOCTOR GOMEZ TO OUR COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR GLAZER AND
SENATOR ROSS. THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING I AM
PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES VICE CHANCELLOR
MINOR AND PRESIDENT- CHAU A TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ABOUT STUDENT
SUCCESS. THIS TEAM IS CENTRAL
TO THE WORK OF THE CSU AND CAL
STATE LA IT IS OUR GUIDING
PRINCIPLE THAT SHAPES OUR
DECISION MAKING OUR PLANS AND
OUR WORK ON BEHALF OF OUR
STUDENTS. CASTELLI IS A
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED HISPANIC
SERVING INSTITUTION. WITH A
STUDENT POPULATION OF MORE THAN
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND.
APPROXIMATELY 58% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS AND 63% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE PELL GRANT
ELIGIBLE. WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF PELL GRANT
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS IN THE CSU
YET WE ARE RANKED NUMBER ONE IN
THE NATION FOR THE UPWARD
MOBILITY OF OUR STUDENTS. THIS
PAST YEAR WE GRADUATED NEARLY
SEVENTY THREE HUNDRED STUDENTS
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF STUDENTS
IN THE HISTORY OF CAL STATE LA.
THE LIVES OF THESE GRADUATES
ARE FOREVER CHANGED BY THE
EDUCATION THEY RECEIVED WE WANT
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS TO REAP THE
REWARDS OF A UNIVERSITY DEGREE.
TO EXPERIENCE UPWARD MOBILITY
AND TO CONTRIBUTE TO AND BECOME
LEADERS IN CALIFORNIA. CAL
STATE LA WE FOCUSED ON THE
CSU'S GI TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
INITIATIVE. THE CSU'S FLAGSHIP
EFFORT TO INCREASE GRADUATION
RATES ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS IN
DEGREE COMPLETION AND MEET
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE NEEDS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THESE CALLS
ARE CONNECTED IF WE ENSURE THE
SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS WE
ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF
CALIFORNIA. THE CSU GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
SETS DISTINCT TARGETS FOR EACH
CSU CAMPUS. BASED ON THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES. THE CSU
HAS RECOGNIZED THE CAST IT AWAY
IS MAKING GOOD PROGRESS TOWARDS
OUR GOAL TOWARDS ITS GOALS. OUR
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE FOR
FIRST TIME STUDENTS AND 17% IT
IS CLIMB FROM 6% AND WE EXPECT
OUR RATE TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE. WE SAW GREATER
SUCCESS WITH OUR SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATE FOR FIRST TIME
STUDENTS ARE SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATE TARGET FOR
FRESHMAN IS FIFTY FIVE PERCENT.
WE ARE STEADILY APPROACHING
THAT RISING FROM 36% TO FIFTY
TWO POINT 5% THIS YEAR. TWO
YEAR GRADUATE THE TWO YEAR
GRADUATION RATE TARGET FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS IS THIRTY SIX
PERCENT. WE HAVE ALREADY
SURPASSED THAT RISING FROM
SIXTEEN PERCENT. LAST YEAR OUR
GRADUATION RATE WAS THIRTY
EIGHT POINT 3% OUR FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS IS NOW SEVENTY SIX
POINT 6% OUR GOAL IS EIGHTY ONE
PERCENT. THE PROGRESS WE'VE
EXPERIENCED AS A RESULT OF
DETERMINATION HARD WORK AND A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
MEETING THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. THE COMPLETION OF THE
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENTS IN THE FIRST YEAR
IS A KEY INDICATOR OF STUDENT
RETENTION AND GRADUATION. A KEY
COMPONENT OF GI TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE WAS A DECISION BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
ELIMINATE REMEDIATION
THROUGHOUT THE CSU AND TO FOCUS
INSTEAD ON ACADEMIC PREPARATION.
THE NUMBER OF OUR STUDENTS WHO
COMPLETED GED MATH AND FULFILL
THE QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENT IN THEIR FIRST YEAR
SHOT UP FROM 49% IN. 2016284%
AND TWENTY NINETEEN. A DECISION
BY THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OPEN
THE DOOR FOR US TO TRY A NEW
APPROACH. OUR FACULTY
OVERHAULED THE MATH CURRICULUM
AND DESIGNED AND IMPLEMENTED A
NEW PLAN. WE CREATED NEW
COURSES THAT WERE MADE MORE
STUDENT CENTERED. MULTI SECTION
COURSES HAVE COORDINATORS AND
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO JUST IN
TIME SUPPORT ACADEMIC COACHES
ASSIST STUDENTS WITH TOPICS
BEYOND THE SUBJECT MATERIAL
SUCH AS TIME MANAGEMENT
PLANNING AND GOAL SETTING
ACCESS TO UNIVERSITY RESOURCES
AND STUDY TIPS. I NEARLY
WARNING SYSTEM BASED ON
ATTENDANCE ASSIGNMENTS AND
PARTICIPATION DATA ALLOWS OUR
INSTRUCTORS TO INTERVENE IN
REAL TIME. WE ALSO INVESTED IN
OUR MATH FACULTY NEARLY SIXTY
OF OUR FACULTY RECEIVED
EXTENSIVE SUPPORT FROM OUR
NATIONALLY ACCLAIMED CENTER FOR
EFFECTIVE TEACHING AND LEARNING.
WE ARE PROUD OF OUR SUCCESS IN
CLOSING THE QUANTITATIVE
REASONING REQUIREMENT
COMPLETION GAP BETWEEN ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS AND NON
STUDENTS AS YOU CANSEE WE HAD
A GAP OF SIXTEEN PERCENTAGE
POINTS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE
HAVE NARROWED THAT TO JUST SIX
PERCENTAGE POINTS. CAL STATE LA
IS NUMBER ONE IN THE NATION FOR
EXCEEDING PREDICTED GRADUATION
RATES ACCORDING TO US NEWS AND
WORLD REPORT. BASED ON THE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND
CHARACTERISTICS OF OUR STUDENTS
AND CAMPUS OUR GRADUATION RATE
WAS PROJECTED TO BE TWENTY
THREE PERCENT. OUR ACTUAL
GRADUATION RATE WAS FIFTY TWO
PERCENT. OVER PERFORMANCE OF
TWENTY NINE PERCENTAGE POINTS
MAKING CASTED A LATE THE TOP IN
THE NATION AMONG PUBLIC AMONG
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES. I'M HAPPY
TO POINT OUT THAT OTHER CSU'S
ARE ALSO TOP PERFORMERS IN FACT
NINE OF THE TOP FIFTEEN TOP
PERFORMERS ARE CSU'S. THIS IS
AN EXTRAORDINARY ACCOMPLISHMENT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. LAST YEAR
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY NAMED CAL STATE LA
A CHAMPION FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
FOR LEADING THE WAY FOR
CREATING PATHWAYS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO OUR UNIVERSITY
THROUGH A SOCIO DEGREES FOR
TRANSFER. THE MAJORITY OF
CASTELLI MAJORS ARE ALIGNED
WITH ASSOCIATE DEGREES FOR
TRANSFER AND FACULTY CONTINUE
TO WORK ON A LINE EVEN MORE
MAJORS WITH SIMILAR EIGHTY
TEASE. THIS IS ANOTHER TOOL WE
USE TO SUPPORT TRANSFER
STUDENTS ON THEIR PATH TO
GRADUATION. IN ADDITION WE ARE
USING OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS. WITH SB FOUR
TWELVE WAS ENACTED WE SAW HOW
FAR WE HAD TO GO BEFORE WE CAN
DELIVER ON THIS PROMISE TO OUR
STUDENTS. TODAY THANKS TO
FINDING SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE
FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND CSU
SYSTEM WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY
WE'RE PROUD TO SAY WE WANT
START CALIFORNIAPROMISE
PROGRAM THIS FALL IT IS ANOTHER
IMPORTANT MEANS OF PROMOTING
AND SUPPORTING GRADUATION IN
FOUR YEARS. FOR FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS AND TWO YEARS FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS WE ARE
AGGRESSIVELY MARKETING THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE TO OUR
STUDENTS THE PROGRAM IS
FEATURED PROMINENTLY ON OUR
HOME PAGE AND IS FEATURED ON AN
EASY TO NAVIGATE WEBSITE. WE'RE
EXCITED TO OFFER INDIVIDUAL
SUPPORT TO OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
DEDICATED TO GRADUATING IN FOUR
OR TWO YEARS. THE PANDEMIC
THREAT AND OUR STUDENTS TO
GRADUATION. MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS COME FROM THE MOST
UNDER RESOURCE AREAS IN OUR
STATE. THEY AND THEIR FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN HARD HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC. TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE
THEIR STUDIES IN SPITE OF THE
PANDEMIC WE TOOK SEVERAL
MEASURES WE PURCHASED THOUSANDS
OF LAPTOPS IN HOT SPOTS WE KNOW
THAT OUR STUDENTS NEED THIS
HELP. WE DISTRIBUTED THIS
TECHNOLOGY THROUGH A CONTACT
FREE PROCESS. ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE FACING
OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
DURING THE COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS STUDENT SECURITY.
WE UNDERSTAND WE NEED TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS WITH BASIC
NEEDS WE HAVE AN ONGOING FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM THROUGH
OUR CHIEF L. A. PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM WITH THE YMCA. WE HAVE
ALSO COLLABORATED WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL FOOD BANK TO
ASSIST OUR STUDENTS THEIR
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AND MEET WE HAVE DISTRIBUTED
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND TWELVE
TONS OF PRODUCE DAIRY DRY GOODS
AND MEET TO NEARLY FIVE
THOUSAND FANS. CASTED ELISCU
PANTRY LOCATED ON CAMPUS
PROVIDES ASSISTANCE ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE TO OUR STUDENTS.
WHEN WE HOST THE KOBE NINETEEN
TESTING SITE ON CAMPUS FOR OUR
CAMPUS AND ROSENIOR MY
COMMUNITIES TO STAY HEALTHY
WE'RE ALSO OFFERING A FREE
DRIVE THRU FLU VACCINATION
CLINIC TOMORROW DURING THIS
EVENT TO CAL STATE LA WE WILL
ALSO DISTRIBUTE GROCERIES AND
DENTAL CARE KITS TO OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR COMMUNITY. IN
THE SPRING WE DISBURSING NEARLY
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
SHARES ACT FUNDING TO ALMOST
TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS. FOUR
WE RECEIVED KERR'S ACTS FUNDING
WE USED UNIVERSITY FUNDS TO
ASSIST STUDENTS WITH EMERGENCY
GRANTS TOTALLING ALMOST THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. SOME
OF OUR STUDENTS WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR CARERS ACT FUNDING
SO WE PROVIDED NEARLY A MILLION
DOLLARS TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR STATUS RECEIVE THE HELP
THEY NEED. OUR FACULTY AND
STAFF ARE CRUCIAL TO OUR
STUDENTS SUCCESS AND TO ALL OF
OUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO TRY TO THRIVE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. OUR
FACULTY SPENT MUCH OF THE
SUMMER PREPARING TO TEACH IN
WAYS THAT CHALLENGE PREPARE AND
ENGAGE OUR STUDENTS IN A
VIRTUAL SPACE. NEARLY EIGHT
THOUSAND FACULTY COMPLETED THE
CENTER FOR EFFECTIVE TEACHING
AND LEARNING ALL INSTRUCTIONS
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDED GREATER TOOLS FOR
TEACHING IN A VIRTUAL SPACE.
OUR STUDENTS BENEFIT FROM A
STELLAR FACULTY WE CONTINUE TO
HIRE TENURE TRACK FACULTY TO
MEET OUR INSTRUCTION IN FALL
TWENTY TWENTY WE WELCOME FIFTY
FIVE NEW TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
OUR SUCCESS IS AN OUTCOME OF
THE DEEP DEDICATION OF OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF TO REQUIRED
AWAY WE PROVIDE SERVICES TO
REMOVE BARRIERS AND TO WORK
CREATIVELY TO MEET THEIR NEEDS.
BUT VIDEO THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE NOW SHOWS SOME OF THE KEY
STEPS WE TOOK ON BEHALF OF OUR
STUDENTS IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN ACADEMIC. STAYED
AWAY WE'VE BEEN WORKING HARD ON
G. I. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. THESE
ARE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES
INSTRUCTED OUR TRADITIONAL WAYS
OF WORKING. WE HAVE TO REDOUBLE
OUR EFFORTS TO MAINTAIN STEADY
IMPROVEMENT IN RETENTION AND
GRADUATION RATES AND A
REDUCTION IN EQUITY. WE'RE
PLANNING TO TAKE A WORK TO THE
NEXT LEVEL BY BUILDING A NEW
CENTER FOR ACADEMIC SUCCESS. IT
WOULD BE A ONE STOP SHOP WHERE
STUDENTS CAN GET PERSONALIZED
ATTENTION AND BE REFERRED TO
SOMEONE WHO CAN IMMEDIATELY
HELP. EITHER YOU'RE AN ACADEMIC
COACH FRIEDMAN A FACULTY MEMBER
OFFICE. IN THE PANDEMIC CARE
AND EVERYTHING. WE WERE
SUDDENLY CAN WITH A ON PRESS
CHALLENGE BEING SCATTERED
ACROSS LOS ANGELES AND MANY OF
US WHICH LIMITED ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY IN DOWN. WE WERE
WORRIED THAT OUR STUDENTS WILL
BE UNABLE TO CONNECT WITH THE
VISORS SO WE PURCHASED
THOUSANDS OF LAPTOPS AND HOT
SPOT. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS TO ESTABLISH
MEANINGFUL CONNECTIONS WITH AT
LEAST ONE PERSON ON CAMPUS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO REMAIN IN
COLLEGE. SO DURING THE PANDEMIC
RELATIONSHIPS BECAME EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT. WE REALIZE THAT WE
NEEDED TO REIMAGINE ADVISING
AND STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES
REMOVE MORE ADMINISTRATIVE
BARRIERS AND USE OUR TECHNOLOGY
TO REWIRE THE WAY WE WORK TOOK
PLACE RELATED TRANSHIPPED FRONT
AND CENTER. WE ACCELERATED OUR
SHIFT TO PROACTIVE ADVISING.
WITHIN TWO WEEKS ALL OF OUR
ADVISORS ACADEMIC COACHES
TUTORS AND PEER LED STUDY GROUP
SEGMENT DESIGNS. WE FOCUSED ON
HELPING OUR STUDENTS BILD
RELATIONSHIPS. AND STAY
CONNECTED. MAYBE CAME INTENSE
ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY. WE SINCE
IN FOLLOWED UP WITH ADDITIONAL
PHONE CALLS AND MOST RECENTLY
TAX MESSAGE. WE NEED EASIER FOR
TO SET UP APPOINTMENTS WITH OUR
EBAY ADVISED SYSTEM. AND FOR
THE FOR TIME EVERY FOR YEARS.
WILL HAVE THEIR OWN MISER. AT
THE END OF SPRING TO ARE TO A
WERE TRUMP HIGHER THEY WERE THE
SAME TIME YEAR AND I CAN. OR UP.
FOR FIFTY. THIS SUMMER WE MOVED.
ON ANY. DIVISORS TO ON OR- AND
CONNECT LIKE BEFORE. EVERY
STILL OUT OF GROUP BY SAYS
BEFORE THE REGS FOR. WE INVITED
ALL STUDENTS TO REMOTE LEARNING
EXPERIENCE IN CAMPUS. THEY
LEARN HOW TO SUBMIT ASSIGNMENTS
AND HOW TO PREPARE FOR CLASS.
IN THE NET OTHER FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS. WE CONTINUE TO BRIDGE
DEVISING WITH ACADEMIC SUPPORT.
WORST WERE UNABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OUR SERVICES
BECAUSE THEY'RE WORKING OR
TAKING CARE OF CHILDREN
SIBLINGS AT HOME. WE REALIZE
THAT WE NEEDED TO MEET OUR
STUDENTS WHERE THEY WERE AT. WE
PROVIDED EVENING AND WEEKENDS.
DURING A COACHING SESSIONS. AND
WE ALSO PROVIDED ONLINE
WEBINARS ON TOPICS RELATED TO
STUDENT SUCCESS WE ARE REACHING
MORE STUDENTS. AND BECOMING
MORE PERSONAL AT THE SAME. OUR
STUDENTS BENEFITED FROM THE
CHANGES THAT WE IMPLEMENT THAT
STUDENTS MAY NOT BE ON CAMPUS
BUT THEY ARE BACK IN CLASS OUR
FIRST YEAR RETENTION RATES ARE
HIGHER THIS YEAR THAN LAST OUR
GRADUATION RATES HAVE CONTINUED
TO CLIMB. AND WE REDUCED OUR AT
THE- DESPITE BEING. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS AND SENATOR
ROSS FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
CSU IN THE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK WITH YOU TO
SUPPORT STUDENT SUCCESS THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU TO A
DOCTOR GOMEZ- FOR YOUR A GREAT
PRESENTATION AND- SOME REALLY
WONDERFUL PROGRESS POINTS THAT
YOU HAVE IDENTIFIED THE DATE
THAT YOU PROVIDED ON MATH
COMPLETION IS INCREDIBLY
IMPRESSIVE AND IMPORTANT- THAT
THE- TOUCHES THE ENHANCED
ADVISING- TRYING TO CREATE
THOSE CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
STUDENTS THEMSELVES AS WELL AS
TO THE CAMPUS. COMMUNITY ARE SO
IMPORTANT AND- SO IMPACTFUL AND
IT'S REALLY IT'S REALLY GREAT
TO HEAR AND THE CITY ME TALKED
ABOUT BEGINNING YOUR CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM THIS YEAR TO
HAVE THAT A NUMBER FOR HOW MANY
HAVE. JOINED THAT PROGRAM. WE I
THINK WE'VE GOT A LITTLE OVER A
HUNDRED. THAT HAVE- US SIGNED
UP FOR HIM- EXPRESSED AN
INTEREST IN THE PROGRAM WE'RE
STARTING IT. AND IN FACT IN THE
SPRING AS WELL. BUT I THINK
THAT AGAIN WHAT WE HEAR FROM
STUDENTS ALL THE TIME IS THAT-
THEY WANT TO GET THROUGH- THEY
KNOW THE CHALLENGES THEY WANT
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
GET THE CLASSES THEY NEED TO
GET THROUGH- AND SO KNOWING
ABOUT THAT FOUR YEAR PATHWAY
AND A COMMITMENT FROM THE
UNIVERSITY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
WILL GET THE CLASSES. AND GIVEN
THAT ENHANCE TO HELP OF FOR UP
FOR EARLY REGISTRATION- AND
ADVISING ANNA IS A BIG
INCENTIVE TO THEM AND I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TO PUBLICIZE THE PROGRAM ON
YOUR CAMPUS BY STAFF HAS SENT
ME A NOTE THAT SAYS IT TAKES
ABOUT FIVE OR SIX CLICKS TO
FIND THE PROGRAM ON YOUR
WEBSITE SO IT'S NOT SO EASY TO
SEE- I HOPE THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE YOUR EFFORTS I MEAN.
THE STORY OF CAL STATE LA AS
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED THEY'RE
SEEING SOME INCREDIBLE
ACCOMPLISHMENT- AND THERE'S
SOME IMPORTANT GROWTH- AS YOU
I'VE INDICATED THAT FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AT YOUR CAMPUS WAS SIX
PERCENT. AND NOW I THINK AS I
SAW ON YOUR SLIDE IT'S MOVED UP
217% THAT'S IT AND THAT'S
IMPRESSIVE GROWTH AT THE SAME
TIME IT IT'S AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES- IN
THE SYSTEM SO WE KNOW. WE HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO AND LET ME JUST
SAY THIS IS A PARTNERSHIP WE
ARE HERE TO HELP YOU AND YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED IN THE CERTAINLY THE
SYSTEM IS IDENTIFIED WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN HELP AND CONTINUE
TO HELP AND I THINK THAT'S PART
OF WHAT WE WANT TO. TALK ABOUT-
FURTHER HERE TODAY I WANT TO
INVITE SENATOR ROTH WHO HAS
BEEN QUIETLY LISTENING AS WELL
AS WE FINISH THIS FIRST PANEL I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR DOCTOR
MINOR BUT I WANTED TO ALLOW
SENATOR ROCK TO SEE IF HE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS YOU'D LIKE TO ASK
TO THAT WONDERFUL. CAMPUS
LEADERS OR TO THE SYSTEM.
SENATE ROTH YOU'RE ON MUTE.
ABOUT UP THERE YOU GOT ABOUT
ELEVEN WHEN YOU'RE MY AGE OF
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS- IN
ADDITION TO THE ONES I ASSUME
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ASKING
ABOUT- BUT IT'S PROGRAM IS
BASED ON THE LIKE BUT GIVEN THE
FACT THAT- MY MUSIC NOW. YEAH
WE HEAR YOU WE HEAR YOU GREAT.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE'RE NOW.
FULLY ENSCONCED IN THIS COVERT
NINETEEN ONLINE ENVIRONMENT AS
THE AS THE SPEAKERS REFERENCED
AND WONDERING IF- OF. CSU
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
BROADBAND ACCESS ISSUES- HAVING
TO DO WITH THEIR ONLINE
ACTIVISTS PATIENT IN THEIR
DEGREE PROGRAMS OR WHETHER THIS
IS LARGELY AN ISSUE THAT THE
CAPE K. THROUGH FOURTEEN- SITES
ARE EXPERIENCING. DR MINOR ARE
YOU STILL WITH US CAN YOU HELP
US SENATE ROTH IN AND THAT
QUESTION. I AM I'LL BE HAPPY TO
TAKE A FIRST PASS AND THEN I'LL
AND BITE MY CAMPUS COLLEAGUES
TO GIVE. A MORE DETAILED- OUR
EXPRESSION WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THEIR CAMPUSES LOCALLY WHAT
WHAT WE SEE SENATOR IS IN DC
YES THERE ARE SOME ISSUES WITH
ACCESSIBILITY. AND OUR ABILITY
TO CHEAP STUDENTS CONNECTED TO
OUR CAMPUSES I WILL SAY FROM
THE SYSTEM OFFERS THAT VARIES
QUITE SUBSTANTIALLY ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. WELL AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
A MORE URBAN AREAS- THE ACCESS
TO BROADBAND IS A LOT MORE THAN
IDEAS ABOUT SOME MORE WAR AREAS
OF THE STATE. AND SOLVED-
STRATEGIES AT OUR CAMPUSES OF
HATS- OUTLINED TO KEEP STUDENTS
CONNECTED TO THE CAMPUSES OF
ALSO VARY QUITE SIGNIFICANTLY
BUT I'LL TELL YOU WHAT THE
CHALLENGES NOT ONLY BROADBAND
ACCESS IT'S ALSO THE
AVAILABILITY OF DEVICES TO
CONNECT SO THAT BROADBAND WHERE
IT EXISTS. AND ONE EXTENSION OF
THAT IS ALSO- APPROPRIATE
LEARNING SPACE THAT STUDENTS
HAVE WHEN CONNECTED. TO REALLY
BE ABLE TO FOCUS AND
CONCENTRATE ON THEIR STUDIES
SALT IT IS ACCESS TO BROADBAND
IT IS THE TECHNOLOGY TO CONNECT
WHERE IT EXISTS AND IT'S ALSO-
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
ADEQUATE SPACE TO ACTUALLY-
FOCUS ON THEIR STUDIES AND
WAVES. THAT KEEP THEM MOVING
TOWARDS THEIR DEGREE. OR WE-
THEN ARE WE WORKING ON THE- A-
THE GENERAL. I REALIZED SOME OF
THIS IS CAMPUS AND REGION
SPECIFIC BUT A GENERAL PLAN TO
DEAL WITH THE BROADBAND ACCESS
ISSUES IN THE DEVICE ISSUES.
THAT WOULD TIE IN TO WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE EITHER HAS DONE
WILL DO OR NEEDS TO. PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND MONEY TO TRY TO
BRIDGE THIS GAP. WE'RE WORKING
THESE ISSUES AND ON THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE ENVIRONMENT. I'M
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE WORK THE ISSUES. IN THE C.
ISSUE ANTIC TO THE EXTENT IT
EXISTS THE UC ENVIRONMENT AS
WELL BUT WE NEED TO WHAT KNOW
WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE WE NEED
THE SYSTEM TO. HELP US THE A
DESIGN A STRATEGY TO DEAL WITH
IT. THANK YOU SENATOR WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT.
I ALSO ALSO WOULD BE INTERESTED
ABOUT THE- NEED TO PROVIDE
BASIC NEEDS SUPPORT TO STUDENTS
IN THE- IN THE CSU SYSTEM I
ASSUME THAT STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH- PLAYS A SIGNIFICANT
FACTOR IN GRADUATION SUCCESS.
AND IF SO- WHAT MENTAL HEALTH
EFFORTS ENHANCED MENTAL HEALTH
EFFORTS AND WE DEVELOPED AND
IMPLEMENTED DURING THIS COUPLE
BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC SENSE I
FRANKLY DON'T THINK THIS THIS
ONLINE SITUATION- AND THIS
PANDEMIC IS GOING TO BE OVER.
THAT SO. SARAH GREY LASER
MADMAN ADDRESS THAT QUESTION OF
COURSE PRESIDENT. Q. IT'S I'M
I'M REALLY GLAD- SERRA WROTE
THAT YOU ASK BOTH OF THOSE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE AS IT TURNS
OUT I HAVE MEANT TO ADDRESS
THEM AND- I FORGOT I HAD THIS.
ONE LESS LIGHT HERE SO I'LL USE
THAT TO- STRUCTURE MY RESPONSE-
THE STUDENTS HAVE BEEN- HAVING
DIFFICULTY STAYING ENGAGED AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE FACING IN THE
VIRTUAL MODALITY- WE'RE ALSO
BECOMING AWARE OF THE HOME AND
FAMILY PRESSURES THAT STUDENTS
AND EVEN FACULTY HAVE FACULTY
WITH ISSUES WITH CHILD CARE AND
SO FORTH AND FINING QUIET TIME.
AND FOR MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY OUR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS IN THE SALINAS VALLEY
AND OTHER AREAS- THEY HAVE-
THEY DON'T HAVE QUITE SPACE AT
HOME THEY HAVE A PRESSURES ON
THEIR TIME THEY NEED THEIR THE-
THE- THERE ARE FAMILY MEMBERS
DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
CAN'T THEY'RE NOT AVAILABLE TO
THEM SO THEY ARE PHYSICALLY- IT
MAKES IT QUITE DIFFICULT AND
THEN THE BROADBAND AND THE
ACCESS TO LAPTOPS IS ARE ALSO
ISSUES. WE HAVE RESPONDED BY
ISSUING- HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF- HOT SPOTS- AND
LAPTOPS TO STUDENTS THAT NEED
THEM- BUT THERE IS A PROBLEM
WITH BROADBAND IF YOU IF YOU
GIVE HOTSPOTS TO STUDENTS THEIR
PARTS SOME PARTS OF OUR COUNTY
WHERE YOU DON'T YOU DON'T HAVE
THE YOU KNOW THE HOSPITAL'S
WORK SO- WE ARE MAY WERE
COLLABORATING WITH THE-
MONTEREY COUNTY- OFFICER
DUCATION- AS WELL AS WITH SOME
AYE REGIONAL. ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT- GROUPS AND THE
COUNTY ITSELF TRYING TO DEVELOP
A- A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY
FRANKLY I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
CALIFORNIA- WOULD BENEFIT IN
MULTIPLE WAYS BY DEVELOPING-
UNIVERSAL BROADBAND ADVOCATE
ACCESS ACROSS THE STATE SOME
THIS IS COMPARABLE TO WHAT SOME
AYE ASIAN- COUNTRIES- ARE DOING
BECAUSE I THINK IT WOULD HAVE A
NOT ONLY A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON
OUR EDUCATIONAL EFFECTIVENESS
BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF OUR
ECONOMY- IN TERMS OF THE
ABILITY TO DRAW IN PEOPLE. INTO
THE- INTERNET ECONOMY ACROSS
THE STATE- IT WOULD BE I THINK
A- I'M- TRANSFORMATIONAL IN FOR.
PROJECT WELL THE LAST THING I
HAD HERE THAT THAT YOU DIDN'T
MENTION THAT IS- IN TERMS OF
WHAT IMPACT THIS IS HAVING ON
OUR CAMPUSES. OF PHYSICAL EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE MAINTAIN A ROMAN
WE DON'T HAVE STUDENTS ON
CAMPUS AND SO ARE OF SIMILAR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
HOUSING AND DINING HAVE BEEN
SEVERELY IMPACTED FINANCIALLY
AND WE'RE- HAVING TO HELP THEM
OUT. BUT WE'RE GONNA HAPPEN YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHETHER I'LL
BE HANDLING IT. IS NEXT YEAR
BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THAT LAST ISSUE. BECAUSE
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
THIS CALL BUT NINETEEN. YOU
HAVE A LOT OF SUNK COST AND
OBLIGATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH-
WITH- HOUSING FACILITIES AND
DINING FACILITIES- THAT THE
STATE DOESN'T PAY TO BUILD AND
THOSE OBLIGATIONS HAVE TO BE
SERVICE SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO. OTHER
COVER THAT GAP FOR YOU SOME WAY
CONSISTENT WITH THE WAY WE DO
OUR BUDGETING IN THE WAY WE
ROLL OUT THE MONEY. AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE BROADBAND
FRANKLY- I WANT TO GET THE
MENTAL HEALTH IN A MINUTE BUT
WITH. RESPECT TO THE BROADBAND
I THINK THIS IS ONE ISSUE WHERE
HIGHER EDUCATION CAN JOIN WITH-
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO THAT
PIECE OF HIGHER ED AND K.
THROUGH TWELVE- SYSTEMS BECAUSE
THE ISSUES ARE THE SAME. OF THE
SOLUTIONS MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IN THE WAY THEY'RE
FUNDED MAY BE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. BUT THE ISSUES OF
THE SAME AND WIENER WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO TACKLE THESE. BECAUSE
FRANKLY I'M NOT SURE WE KNOW
WHAT THE FUTURE. OF ON SITE
EDUCATION REALLY LOOKS LIKE.
AND THAT ALSO INVOLVES PERHAPS
PERHAPS- CONCEPT OF LEARNING
CENTERS COUPLED WITH CHILD CARE
IN A COLD ENVIRONMENT BETTER-
THE CONSTRUCTOR TO AND OPERATED
IN ACCORDANCE WITH CDC
GUIDELINES BUT IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING A QUIET SPACE FOR
LEARNING A WHILE YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE TAKING CARE OF
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO RETHINK
THAT TO AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO.
HOW TO PROPERLY FUND- THE- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT AND
DOING IT IN A WAY THAT COMPLIES
AS I SAID WITH. WITH THE COVERT
ROLES IN THE CDC GUIDELINES I
THINK THAT'S CRITICAL AND I DO
WANT TO FURTHER EXPLORE NOT
PERHAPS IN THIS IN THIS SETTING
THEY WANT TO HIJACK MY CHURCH
HEARING BUT IF YOU WANT TO
EXPLORE MENTAL HEALTH BECAUSE
I'M NOT SURE THAT WE REALLY
CRACKED THE NUT ON THAT. HOW WE
HOW WE FUNDED ON YOUR CAMPUSES-
IN EARLIER HEARINGS PEOPLE
SPOKE TO ME ABOUT THE WARM HAND
OFF BUT WHEN YOU DO THE WARM
HAND OFF FROM YOUR CAMPUS- TO
THIS CIVILIAN I WOULD CALL THEM
CIVILIAN PROVIDERS- IT'S ONLY
WARM SO LONG AS SOMEBODY HAS A
HAS A- METHOD AND MEANS TO PAY
FOR THE SERVICES. AND WE HAVE
AN ADDRESS THAT. QUESTION SURE
THOSE ARE MY TWO- TWO SECURITY
QUESTIONS AND I DID FOR YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH AND- I WOULD LIKE TO PAY
YOU BACK ON YOUR CONCERN THAT
YOU'VE RAISED ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH WE- AT THE- STUDENTS
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING THAT
WE HELD A CAL POLY POMONA THAT
YOU PARTICIPATED IN IN FACT WE
TALKED ABOUT. MENTAL HEALTH
DURING THAT SESSION- AND THE
FACTOID THAT IF THE STUDENT IS
IN NEED OF SOME- COUNSELING
HELP SOME STRESS- THAT THEY'RE
FACING THAT COULD JEOPARDIZE
THEIR- CONTINUATION OF THEIR
STUDIES. THAT THE AVERAGE WAIT
TIME FOR AN APPOINTMENT- IN THE
SYSTEM WAS THREE WEEKS. AND- AS
WE PULL WE ALL KNOW. THAT IF
YOU UNDER STE SAID YOU CAN GET
ANY HELP THREE WE- IT'S- REALLY
A OOD SITUATION AT ALL. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND THERE BUDGET
REPLIED REQUEST LAST YEAR. DID
COME FORWARD WITH A SPECIFIC
REQUEST FOR ASSISTANCE IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH AREA- BUT THE CSU
DID NOT. AND AT THAT TIME A
YEAR AGO I SAID AND I REITERATE
THAT I WOULD. ENCOURAGE THE CSU
TO LOOK MORE CAREFULLY AT THIS
AREA MENTAL HEALTH ON THE
CAMPUSES- WITH THE POTENTIAL
FOR AGAIN THIS IS ALL ABOUT
PARTNERSHIPS. THAT WE HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE ONE OUR
CAMPUSES AND OUR STUDENTS TO
SUCCEED. AND WE OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE AT OUR DISPOSAL BUT- WE
WANTED TO BE USED IN THE BEST
WAY AND I THINK THAT. SENATE
ROTH IT YOU HIGHLIGHTING THIS
AGAIN TODAY- AND MY COMMENTS I
THINK SPEAK TO THAT. HOW CUTE
WE SEE THAT ISSUE AND HOW
CONNECTED IT IS TO STUDENT
SUCCESS AND HOW WE HAVE TO. DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP. THE
CAMPUSES- PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES- WHEN THEY'RE NEEDED
NOT IN THREE WEEKS AND WE WE'VE
GOT IT WE GOTTA FIND A WAY TO
DO THAT BETTER. SO I APPRECIATE
SENATOR OUGHT TO BRING THAT
ISSUE UP AGAIN AND I HOPE THAT
WE CAN. CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ON THAT SPECIFIC
POINT- EVEN THOUGH WE'RE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATES. THAT WE KNOW
HOW CONNECTED THAT IS. I LIKE
TO BRING BACK THE DOCTOR MINOR
AYE AYE- SO APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THE SYSTEM. IT'S A
CHALLENGING PLACE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW YU'RE NOT RUNNING THINGS
HERE GUIDING THE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES AND I. APPRECIATE THE
CHALLENGES THAT COME INTO PLAY-
IN THAT REGARD- BUT WE HAVE
THAT SCENE- IN DOUBT THAT THE
DATA THAT YOU HAVE PROVIDED-
AND HEARD ABOUT TODAY THAT. WE
ARE WE HAVE CAMPUSES THAT HAVE
ROBUST ENGAGEMENTS AT AND IS
FOR YOUR PATHWAY- AS I
MENTIONED SACRAMENTO STATE SAN
JOSE STATE LONG BEACH. THEY ARE
VERY ROBUST PARTICIPATION IN
THE FOUR YEAR PROGRAM OVER TWO
THOUSAND. STUDENTS IN MANY OF
THE CAMPUSES BUT ON SOME OF THE
OTHERS AND I'M I'M GLAD TO HEAR
IT CAL STATE LA THEY'RE
BEGINNING THE PROGRAM THIS
YEAR. THERE REALLY HASN'T BEEN-
THESE PROGRAM- OFFERED. AND IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE AREN'T
GREAT ACTIVITIES THAT THE
SYSTEM AT THE CAMPUSES ARE
DOING TO. ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO
TAKE FULL COURSE LOADS IN THE
REST. CERTAINLY THOSE HAVE BEEN
IMPRESSIVE AND YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF THEM IN
YOUR TESTIMONY AS AS. WE'VE
HEARD FROM SOME OF THE OTHER
CAMPUSES. BOB BUT AGAIN I GO
BACK TO THE POINT THAT IF
STUDENTS KNOW ABOUT THE FOR
YOUR PATH THEY KNOW THEY CAN
GET ON IT THEY WANT TO GET ON
IT BUT THEY HAVE TO KNOW. THAT
IT'S THERE CAN YOU TALK TO ME
ABOUT HOW YOU ARE WORKING WITH
THE CAMPUS IS THAT- DON'T HAVE
PROGRAMS AT ALL OR HAVE VERY
SMALL PARTICIPATION TO GET THEM
TO DO MORE TO. PUBLICIZE IT AND
TO MAKE THAT OFFERING AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR I THINK IT'S
A VERY. GOOD OBSERVATION ABOUT
IN TERMS OF THE VARIANCES
ACROSS CAMPUSES. I DO JUST WANT
TO MENTION WITH THE
PARTICIPATION AND OUR- PROMISE
PROGRAM. CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM- THE WAYS IN WHICH
WE'RE FEATURING THE PROGRAM ARE
EVOLVING AND I THINK THE LAST
TIME. I WAS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE WE MENTIONED NOW THAT
EVERY SINGLE STUDENT THAT
APPLIES TO THE C. ISSUE- HAS AN
OPTION THE EXPRESS THEIR
INTEREST IN THIS PROGRAM AND
THAT'S THE ISSUE APPLY PORTAL
WHICH IS WHERE EVERY STUDENT
APPLIES TO THE CSU. SO THAT IS
LED TO US BEING ABLE TO
IDENTIFY STUDENTS WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN THE PROGRAM.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THIS THAT I JUST
WANT TO BE CAREFUL AND CLEAR
ABOUT THE OTHER HAS TO DO WITH
THE SHIFT ON OUR CAMPUSES- TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE STUDENTS NOT
ONLY A FULL COURSE LOAD OR
FIFTEEN UNITS BUT IT'S THE
RIGHT FIFTEEN UNITS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR
PARTICULAR DEGREE PROGRAM SO I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE ALSO SEEING.
OUR CAMPUSES DO OVER TIME IS TO
BE ABLE TO MAXIMIZE THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE AVAILABLE
COURSES ON THEIR CAMPUSES A
LINE THOSE COURSES WITH DEGREE
PROGRAMS AND I'LL GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE I WAS SPEAKING WITH THE
STUDENT- LAST TERM- THE
INTERESTED IN TAKING. UNITS IN
TO TAKE A LOOK HER. HOWEVER THE
FIFTY UNITS WORKS. WITH HER
DEGREE PROGRAM TAKE THIS COURSE
NOT BACKWARDS. ONE IN.
AVAILABLE ENACT HER. AND SO SHE
COULD HAVE TAKEN A FULL LOCAL
BUT SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN TAKING
COURSES THAT WERE NOT ALIGNED
WITH HER DEGREE PROGRAMS SO
SOME OF IT IS A BILE- REALIZING
GREATER EFFICIENCY AND
ALIGNMENT AND OF COURSE
SCHEDULE. AND THEN THE THIRD
COMPONENT OF THIS I THINK IS
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT IS JUST
YOUR CAPACITY. AND SO YOU'RE
SEEING SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES
MADE VERY VERY- ARCHES BUT ALSO
DIFFICULT DECISIONS ABOUT
INVESTING IN- COURSE SCHEDULE
IN THE CAPACITY ON THEIR CAMPUS
TO DELIVER THOSE COURSES NOT
ONLY FOR STUDENTS WHO. HAVE
INDICATED INTEREST IN- PROMISE
PROGRAM BUT FOR ALL STUDENTS
ACROSS THE CAMPUS AND SO MY
EXPECTATION SENATORS THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO SEE AN UPTICK
BOTH IN THE PARTICIPATION IN
THE PROGRAM. AND THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WERE TAKEN UP FOR
COURSE LOW AND I THINK THE
PROMISING INDICATION FOR US IS
WHAT WE'RE SEEING. AMONG OUR
FIRST YEAR STUDENTS AND BOTH
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN THAT
POPULATION. FOR INDEED TAKEN A
FULL LOW. WELL THE YOU AND
THOSE ARE UPS. AND I- I TAKE
THEM TO HEART AND IT MATCHES UP
WITH WHAT A LOT OF STUDENTS I
HAVE SAID IT WHICH IS THAT THEY
CAN'T GET THE COURSES THEY NEED
TO GET THROUGH. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY THERE MAY BE SOME
RESISTANCE ON SOME OF THE
CAMPUSES TO FULLY PUBLICIZED.
THE PROGRAM BECAUSE IT MAKES IT
CLEAR THE COMMITMENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY TO. CREATE THAT
PATHWAY AND MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS CAN GET THOSE COURSES
SO THEY CAN GET THROUGH. IT IS
A DILEMMA WHEN WE WANT OUR
UNIVERSITIES TO BE AS OPEN AND
WELCOMING AS POSSIBLE TO AS
MANY STUDENTS AS POSSIBLE. AND
YOUR ENROLLMENT GROWTH SPEAKS
TO WHAT A GREAT VALUE IT IS
AND- AND THE IMPORTANCE THAT
STUDENTS SEE AND TRYING TO- IN
ROLE AT SCSU. BUT THEN IT
STUDENTS ARE GETTING THROUGH.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S A LOT OF
UNFORTUNATE FAILURE- BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE TAKING ON THE
DEBT THEY'RE TAKING A TIME BUT
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THEIR
DEGREE SO WE HAVE TO TRY TO
FIND THAT BALANCE. WE HAVE TO
BE PRIORITIZED. DIG WHEN THE
STUDENT IS IN A ROLE WE HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE MAKING SURE THEY CAN
BE SUCCESSFUL- AND THAT'S
THAT'S A CHALLENGING THING TO
DO BECAUSE AGAIN WE WANT TO BE
OPEN ARMS TO- TO EVERYONE- I-
YOU KNOW WHAT. IT A
FOUNDATIONAL ELEMENT OF THE
PROMISE PROGRAM IS THE FOCUS ON
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS- AND
THAT THE PRIORITY FOR
REGISTRATION THE PRIORITY FOR-
ENGAGEMENT- WITH THE STUDENTS
IS ON THE UNDER REPRESENTED SO
IT DOES GO TO THE HEART OF
WHAT. APPEARS TO BE THE STILL
THE ONE OF THE BIGGER STICKING
BLOCKS TOOK THE PROGRESS. IN
THE GRADUATION- INITIATIVE IS
THOUGH UNDER REPRESENTED. SO WE
HAVE TO MATCH THOSE THINGS UP
AND- AGAIN I SAID THIS IS A
PARTNERSHIP AND WE WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP YOU-
AND SUCCEEDING. IN DOING SO.
ONE OF THE THAT THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE- IN TERMS OF
SETTING POLICY IS THE
AVAILABILITY OF DATA. BECAUSE
WE WANT THE FACTS ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN ALL ASPECTS OF
STATE GOVERNMENT INCLUDING
HIGHER EDUCATION. AND SO WE ARE
INTERESTED IN UNDERSTANDING WHO
IS PARTICIPATING IN THE PROMISE
PROGRAM ARE WE REACHING THE
CONSTITUENCIES THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO REACH WITH IT IN
TERMS OF UNDER REPRESENTED. AND
SO- I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN
SPEAK TODAY OR WE CAN TALK AND
FOLLOW UP OUTSIDE OF THIS
HEARING. BUT WE REALLY ARE
LOOKING FOR THAT THAT THAT THAT
THE DATA THAT'S BEEN COLLECTED
ON THE PROMISE PROGRAM AND WHO.
WHO ARE WE HELPING ARE WE HELP
AND WE WANT TO HELP EVERYBODY
BUT ARE WE HELPING THE RIGHT
FOLKS ARE WE INVESTING OUR
RESOURCES IN THE RIGHT WAY. I
KNOW THAT'S YOUR- COMMITMENT AS
WELL- AND THE AVAILABILITY OF
THAT DATA REALLY WOULD HELP ALL
OF US. MAKE SURE WE'RE MAKING
THE BEST CHOICES DR MINOR.
WHENEVER I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION AND I WILL TAKE
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO GO BACK
TO OUR TEAM- IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO GET AS
MUCH INFORMATION AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN ABOUT PRECISELY WHO'S
PARTICIPATING. AND THE PROMISE
PROGRAM ACROSS OUR CAMPUSES BUT
I THINK. THE DELICATE BALANCE
THAT YOU JUST ARTICULATED IS SO
TRUE. PARTICULARLY WITH UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS OR
STUDENTS WERE THE FIRST IN
THEIR FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE
FOR FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS
FOR OUR STUDENTS WHO COME FROM
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. AND THIS
BALANCE BETWEEN MAKING IT
AVAILABLE TO ALL STUDENTS AND
THEM BEING ABLE TO FULLY
CAPITALIZE ON THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE A FULL COURSE LOAD WE
KNOW. THAT THOSE STUDENTS TEND
TO. BE MORE LIKELY TO WORK. NO
STUDENTS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE FAMILY OBLIGATIONS THEREBY
AND PERHAPS IN SOME CASES NOT
ALL CASES LIMITING THEIR
ABILITY. TO ACTUALLY TAKE
FIFTEEN UNITS IN ANY GIVEN
SEMESTER SOL I THINK IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION AND ONE THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING. SOME
ONGOING CONVERSATION ABOUT. AB
TERRIFIC AND I WE'RE GETTING
FROM THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE IN A MOMENT. WHO CAN
TALK ABOUT- COURSE LOADS- AND I
THINK THEY'RE STUDY SHOWS THAT
I THINK YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
COURSE LOADS HAVE REALLY GONE
UP OVER THE LAST THREE OR FOUR
YEARS I MEAN AGAIN IT'S TAKE A
CREDIT TO THAT. CAMPUS
LEADERSHIP IN THE FACULTY AND
THE AND THE SYSTEM. TO SEE THAT
<c.cyan>ROWTH IN AND COURSE LOADS- BUT</c>
EIGHT EIGHT. I'M NOT SO SURE
THAT THE WORK OBLIGATION IS
NECESSARY EIGHTY EIGHT
DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN A
STUDENT'S DESIRED IT STILL TAKE
THE FULL COURSE LOAD TO GET
THROUGH IN FOUR YEARS. THEY
KNOW THE ECONOMICS OF THE
MATTER TO- THAT THE QUICKER
THEY CAN GET 2 DEGREES THE MORE
MONEY THEY'RE GOING TO SAVE.
THE GREATER OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
MORE AND ENTER OUR ECONOMIC
SYSTEM. SO AT LEAST THE DATA
THAT I HAVE SEEN IS THAT THAT
THAT- THERE ISN'T A BIG
DIFFERENTIAL- IN- THE STUDENTS
WHO ARE TRYING TO TAKE THAT
FULL COURSE LOAD TO AND OTHER
ASPECTS OF THEIR LIFE SO. AB
ALTHOUGH I KNOW THAT THEIR
THEIR PRESENCE- WITH MANY STILL
IN ANY CASE- I I'VE I THANK YOU
AGAIN I THINK I WANT TO SAY.
CHANCELLOR WHY IS CLOSE TO
RETIREE I THINK THAT THIS.
GRADUATION INITIATIVE IS ONE OF
HIS GREATEST ACCOMPLISHMENTS-
ABDOMEN MANY. AS LEADER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. AND DR MINOR I THINK
YOU HAVE BEEN BY HIS SIDE-
CHEERLEADING AND GUIDING OUR
CAMPUS. IN DOING SOME GREAT
WORK HERE IN THIS AREA. AND I
APPLIED TO ALL OF YOUR GOOD
WORK AND I CERTAINLY- CELEBRATE
CHANCELLOR WHITE'S RETIREMENT-
GIVEN SOME OF THESE INCREDIBLE
SUCCESSES. AT TAT THE SYSTEM
IS HAVING CERTAINLY THE CAMPUS
IS DIRECTLY. ARE HAVING AND
GETTING. STUDENTS THROUGH TO
GRADUATION- IT'S A GREAT GREAT
CHEAP AND PLEASE EXTEND. OUR
GOOD WISHES TO CHANCER WHITE-
ON HIS WELL DESERVED RETIREMENT.
OKAY I WANT TO THANK- DOCTOR
MINOR I WANT TO THANK
PRESIDENT- CHILL I WANT TO
THANK DR GóMEZ FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THIS FIRST
PANEL PROVIDING THE GREAT
INSIGHT THAT WE HAVE FOR TODAY.
AND I WANT TO REITERATE AND I
KNOW SENATOR ROTH SHARES THESE
THOUGHTS WHICH IS THAT. WE THIS
IS A PARTNERSHIP AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO THIS PROGRESS WE
WANT TO CONTINUE THIS WORK
TOGETHER AND WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT IT- AND EXCITED ABOUT THE
PROGRESS THAT YOU ALL HAVE. HAD
MADE IN HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT TODAY
SO WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
YOUR- GREAT LEADERSHIP. THANK
YOU SENATORS OKAY WE'RE GONNA
TURN NEXT TO SOME OTHER AT
GREAT- IT EXPERTS AND THEN
FOLKS WITH GREAT INSIGHT ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
CAMPUSES I WOULD LIKE TO TURN
NEXT TO DR JACOB JACKSON HE IS
A RESEARCH FELLOW AT THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION
CENTER. HIS RESEARCH INCLUDES
WORK ON COLLEGE COSTS COLLEGE
READINESS. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PARTICIPATION ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND COLLEGE
COMPLETION. BEFORE JOINING P.
P. I SEE DOCTOR JACKSON WAS A
POSTDOCTORAL SCHOLAR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
A MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER IN SACRAMENTO IN
COLUMBIA MISSOURI. HE'LL TO PHD
IN EDUCATION FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
AND A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
EDUCATION FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF MISSOURI- DOCTOR JACKSON
WELCOME I KNOW YOU THOUGHT JUST
COMPLETED SOME IMPORTANT
RESEARCH THAT- YOU PUBLISHED
AND THAT YOU WILL SHARE WITH US
TODAY WE WELCOME YOU TO OUR
COMMITTEE SIR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANKS ARE GLAZER. THAN
SEVEN IN A ROW. OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFIED. MY NAME'S JACOB
JACKSON I'M RESEARCH FELLOW AT
UPAC ADOPTED NONPARTISAN POLICY
RESEARCH FOR COMMENTS TODAY ARE
ABOUT A RECENT REPORT ON COURSE
TAKING ON TIME COMPLETION AT
THE AT THE CSU- SO. AS YOU'VE-
A CUSTOMER TODAY THIS ISSUE IS
ACTUALLY MAKING IMPRESSIVE
STRIDES TOWARD ITS GRADUATION
INITIATIVE GOAL OF 70% SIX
YEARS AND 40% WITHIN FOUR
YEARS. HOWEVER FEWER THAN A
THIRD OF UNDERGRADUATE YOU
FINISH YOUR DEGREE IN FOUR
YEARS. EACH YEAR A STUDENT
SPENDS EACH ADDITIONAL YEAR
STUDENT SPENDSTHE IN COLLEGE
COMES WITH ASSOCIATED COSTS NOT
JUST TUITION ABOUT THE BOOKS BE.
BUT DEGREE IN THAT AT MORE
SIGNIFICANT HOWEVER IT IS THE
OPPORTUNITY COST OF NOT
ENTERING THE WORK FORCE OR SEE
A DOCTOR THEY WELL THAT COSTS
AROUND FORTY FIVE THE FIRST
OUTING- WORKERS AT SEE IF YOU
ARE AT THEIR GRADUATION THIS
YEAR AND MOREOVER HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS OFTEN
CATERS EXTRA COSTS AS THEIR
PERSISTENT GAPS IT FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES BY RACE FAMILY
INCOME. AND FIRST GENERATION
STATUS. WHAT WAY TO CLOSE GAPS
A FOCUS ON GAPS IN OPPORTUNITY.
AND OUR RECENT REPORT WE LOOK
AT ONE ASPECT BONTA GRADUATION
WHICH IS COURSE TAKING EARLY
AND A COLLEGE STUDENT'S COLLEGE
CAREER. ENABLING AND
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS TAKE FULL
COURSE LOADS HAS BEEN A MAJOR
FOCUS OF THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
AS WELL AS A CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM. IN A RESEARCH WE USED
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA FROM
THE CSU HER ALL THE- BUT ALSO
USED FOR OUR CAPTAINS WHO
VOLUNTEERED I. LONGITUDINAL
STUDENT- I MADE IT THROUGH OR A
SIMPLE THE TODAY I'LL JUST
QUICKLY CHECK OUR OUR MAIN FIRE.
THE FIRST DO NOT JACKSON JUST
HOLD ON I JUST DOCTOR JACKSON
FINANCIALLY PURPOSES OF COURSE
THANK YOU JACKSON HOLD ON FOR
JUST ONE SECOND WE'RE I THINK
WE'RE HAVING A LITTLE TECHNICAL
ISSUE I WANT TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO CLEAR IT
UP SO THAT YOUR- YOUR- VOICE
COMES IN BETTER. ALL RIGHT YOU
COULD BE THE. MAYBE A BETTER. I
SAY THAT AGAIN DOCTOR JACKSON'S
IT IS JUST IT ANY BETTER THE
LITTLE BIT THAT. YEAH RIGHT
I'LL BE ALLOWED IN A STAY OUT
THANK YOU. BURKE STUDENTS
SURVIVAL TIME AT- TO. BUT IT
TAKES IN A OF THREE MINUTES
THIRTY PER YEAR I'M- BUT
STUDENT. ENROLLS ABOUT THIRTEEN
UNIT BURKE THE MOST RECENT DATA
AROUND 43% OF UNDER ENROLLING
TO. JUST A THIRD ONLY FIVE
YEARS. THANK YOU JACK AGAIN LET
ME ADD AGAIN WORK ARE MORE
LIKELY TO DOCTOR JACKSON
INTERNET YOU. I THINK THE TECH
WE HAVE SOME TECH ISSUES THAT
YOU I THINK THE IT THAT I'M
FROM TECHNICAL STAFF IS FOR YOU
TO. DISCONNECT AND RECONNECT
AGAIN. AND SO THE ME ASK YOU TO
TRY TO DO THAT IF YOU WILL. AND
WHILE YOU'RE DOING THAT LET ME
BRING IN A STUDENT THAT DO.
THAT ALSO PROVIDE TO ABOUT. TO
YOUR TECHNICAL ISSUES. HI ED IF
YOU COULD TALK WITH THEM
DIRECTLY YOU HAVE IS NUMBER SO
YOU CAN WORK WITH HIM TO GET. A
BETTER CONNECTION. OKAY BUT SO
LET ME DO THIS FOR WE'RE
WAITING AT OUR WORK. ON THAT
THAT. WE HAVE A STUDENT LEADER
BUT TO. IN THIS- HEARING TODAY-
ZARA. KERR I'D THAT. IS IN
ADDED I. TO FROM CO. WHO
SERVICES THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CAL. STATE STUDENTS SO SHE- SHE
RECEIVED HER BACK. DEGREE AND
SO AND- AT CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE.
AND IS PURSUING A MASTER'S OF
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERING AT. ALSO
AT NORTHRIDGE- DURING HER TIME
AS AN UNDERGRADUATE SHE SERVED
AS A VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATED STUDENTS. LAST YEAR
SHE WAS THE CHAIR OF THE CSSA.
I CONGRATULATE HER ON HER
EXCELLENT. PROGRESS ON HER
STUDIES AND- BUDGETS ARE ARE
YOU THERE. NEXT TRIP CHECK WELL
I HOPE YOU'VE BEEN LISTENING TO
THIS IN INFORMATIVE FACT
CONVERSATION WITH HAVING SO FAR
AND WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY
WHILE WE WAIT TO CLEAR UP
DOCTOR JACKSON'S TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS. WELCOME THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING CHAIR GLAZER AND
SENATOR ROCK- AS MENTIONED
EARLIER MY NAMES ARE CREATED
AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CAL STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION
WHICH REPRESENTS NEARLY HALF A
MILLION CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. I AM A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE
PURSUING A MASTER'S
INSTRUCTIONS HEARING. I AM
PLEASED TO BE HERE THIS MORNING
TO TALK ABOUT MY FELLOW
STUDENTS AND THE HARDSHIPS THAT
THEY'RE EXPERIENCING THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN A RECENT
STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMISSION 71%
OF STUDENTS REPORTED LOSING
SOME OR ALL OF THEIR INCOME.
AND 46% REPORTED EXPERIENCING A
CHANGE IN THEIR LIVING
SITUATION. A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF RESPONSE AND RESPONDENTS
ALSO REPORTED CONCERN ABOUT
PAYING YOUR TUITION AND FEES AS
WELL AS PAYING FOR TECHNOLOGY
AND FOOD. THESE NUMBERS MATCH
WHAT WE AS HE'S A HAPPY HEARING
FROM OUR FELLOWS. OVER THE LAST
NINE MONTHS. MANY STUDENTS ARE
STILL STRUGGLING WITH ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY WHETHER THAT IS
ACCESS TO A LAPTOP OR RELIABLE
AFFORDABLE INTERNET CONNECTION.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN A HIGHER
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS STRUGGLING
OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. THESE ISSUES
WHERE THEY'RE VERY LONG AND
PRESENT BEFORE COLBERT
NINETEEN. A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STUDY DONE BY THE CSU
FOUND THAT FORTY ONE POINT 6%
OF OUR STUDENTS WERE FOOD
INSECURE IN TEN POINT 9% OF OUR
STUDENTS REPORTED EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE PAST TWELVE
MONTHS. ANOTHER MAJOR AREA OF
CONCERN FOR STUDENTS AS MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES. STUDENTS ARE
FACING ANXIETY STRESS. AND
DEPRESSION AS THEY CONFRONT THE
CHALLENGES OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
AND ADAPTING TO A VIRTUAL
ENVIRONMENT MANY STUDENTS HAVE
REPORTED THAT THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS
AND AS MENTIONED EARLIER THE
WAIT TIMES TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT ARE TOO LONG. MORE
THAN EVER STUDENT STUDENTS
EMPHASIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
FINANCIAL AID IN ACHIEVING
THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATION. ABOUT
80% OF CSU STUDENTS RECEIVE
SOME SORT OF FINANCIAL AID WELL
ARMED WELL AROUND- 60% HAVE A
TUITION FULLY COVERED. ALTHOUGH
THE COUNT STATE AID SYSTEM
COVERS FOR THE MAJORITY OF CS
STUDENT ACOSTA JEWISH. THAT THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE WITH.
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE WHICH
INCLUDES THE COST OF HOUSING
FOOD TRANSPORTATION BOOKS AND
SUPPLIES ARE NOT WELL COVERED.
THIS LEADS MANY OF OUR LOW
INCOME AND UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS TO TAKE OUT
SIGNIFICANT DEBT. A REPORT DONE
BY CSSA. WHEN THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
DECUS FOUND THAT EIGHTY IN C.
IS USED WHO GRADUATED THAT HAD
OR CAN FROM. OF AN FAMILY IN.
OF FOURTH DOLLARS A LESS.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE THE OVER
PERCENTAGE OF SPECIES TO
GRADUATE WITH DEBT AROUND
FIFTY. THE STUDY THAT SO 6%
AFTER AND STUDENTS GRADUATE
WITH THE- THIS IS A NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN OUR STATE.
BOTH THINK AND TIMES AND TO
WORK TO THE TRYING TO. WELL
THERE ISN'T ANTICIPATION
FEDERAL REDUCE THE CAR DUE TO
THE PENDING. WE HAVE SEEN OUR
NUMBERS IN. THIS IS PROM AS
GIVE WITHIN A THAT THE CSU OR-
WITH THE GI TRI FIVE NAY. THESE
NUMBERS WOULD NOT BE. WITHOUT
THE PROCESS OF OURS. ARE
FACULTY STAFF. AS AN FOCUSED
ORGANISED. AND WE'RE GOING TO.
SEES THIS IS ALL PLEASED TO SEE
THE- THAT THE G. I. TO TWENTY
FIVE HAS MADE IN ELIMINATING
THE EQUITY GAPS. THIS IS ALSO
RECOGNIZED THE IN OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROBLEMS PROGRAM
WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WAS AUTHORED
BY TWO BY TERROR GLAZER. IN
TERMS OF PARTICIPATION IN THE
FALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN SEASONS
HE WAS HAPPY TO SEE THAT SEVEN
THOUSAND AND SIXTY SIX NEW
STUDENTS PARTICIPATED IN THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM.
FOUNDED WE SEE OR LAWSUIT ARE
FAKE. A ENORMOUS. AND MIX OF
GLOBAL KIND. MANY STE STILL
HOPE. SEVEN OR FOR US TO MOVE
FOR WE ASK THAT THERE IS A KING
TO INVEST- AND COLLABORATION.
IN OUR STUDENTS SO THAT NOT WE
ONLY SUCCEED BUT WE MAY SURVIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SORRY
EFFORTS FOR THAT- WONDERFUL
INSIGHT WE APPRECIATED OF
COURSE YOUR FOCUS ON FINANCIAL
AID AND STUDENT DEBT. IS ROTH
IS RIGHT ON THE MARK- AND OF
COURSE- THE WORST OF ALL IS
THAT A STUDENT WHO ENCOURAGED
THAT DEBT- AND THEN ISN'T ABLE
TO GET THEIR DEGREE- THAT
THAT'S A REAL BIG TRAGEDY AND-
UNFORTUNATELY THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS ARE IN SEEM TO BE IN
THAT POSITION EVERY YEAR AND- I
KNOW ALL OF OUR HEARTS GO OUT
TO THEM AND THAT'S- THAT'S OF
COURSE WE'RE TRYING TO THAT GAP
WE MUST CLOSE IT WE JUST MUST-
IT SAID- YOU KNOW I DREAM
CRASHING. ON THE ROCKS WHEN-
THEY CAN'T FINISH AND- AND ALL
OF US SERVE COMMITTED TO TRYING
TO FIND THOSE BOTTLENECKS THE
ROAD BLOCKS THAT ARE CREATING
THAT. BARRIER TO COMPLETION- DO
YOU FIND OUT WHEN YOU TALK TO
THE STATE- IT THE STUDENT
COMMUNITY AND I KNOW WE'RE
DOING YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO
GENERALIZE IT YOU KNOW ITS
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES. ALL OF
THEM HAVE UNIQUE SITUATIONS.
YOU'VE HEARD SOME OF THE
EARLIER. THAT ON SOME CAN. SAN
JOSE AND CAL STATE LONG BEACH
INSECT STATE THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN ROLLED. IN
THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM
WHERE THEY KNOW THAT FOR YOUR
PAST THAT THEY DO SO. THEY TAKE
THE FIFTEEN UNITS THAT THERE'S
AGO PROMISE A GUARANTEE THAT
THEY CAN GET THROUGH IN FOUR
YEARS. SO WE HAVE A ROBUST
PARTICIPATION ON SOME CAMPUSES
AND THEN THEN WE HAVE A DESERT
IN OTHERS YOU HAVE ANY INSIGHT
OVER THAT ON THAT ISSUE. I
THINK YOU KNOW TO HARM HONEST
HERE. IT'S JUST LIKE YOU SAID
VASTLY DIFFERENT ACROSS THE CSU
SO IT REALLY IS I THINK AT THIS
POINT JUST CAMPUS DEPENDENT AND
THE EFFORTS THAT EACH CAMPUS
ONE SUPPORT- IN PROMOTING THE
PROGRAM. WELL IT WE APPRECIATE
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE CSSA AND-
ND WOULD WELCOME THE
PARTNERSHIP AND TRYING TO BRING
THE AWARENESS OF THAT PROGRAM
TO SOME OF THESE CAMPUSES THAT
HAVE LOW PARTICIPATION RATES.
SO LOW WE COULD WORK TOGETHER
TO IMPROVE FINANCIAL AID. AND
TRIAL LOWER OR ELIMINATE
STUDENT DEBT. THAT WE CAN MAKE
A MORE STUDENTS AWARE OF THIS
CLEAR PATHWAY TO SUCCESS THAT
THAT IS OUT THERE FOR THEM. BUT
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WITH US TODAY AND
THEN OF COURSE THE- THAT THE
GREAT PARTNERSHIP THAT THE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION HAS HAD
WITH MANY OF US HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING INVOLVED. I JUST
WANT TO CHECK US SENATE ROTH
BEFORE WE GO ON WITH THE YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THERE. BUT
THE NUMBERS I JUST WANT TO-
COMMENDED THE TESTIMONY VERY
VERY- VERY VERY IMPORTANT I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
ESPECIALLY ABOUT THE BROADBAND
IN MENTAL HEALTH AS WELL AS
THE- COST OF EDUCATION AND
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WORK ON
THAT SO. KEEP DOING A GREAT JOB
YOU'RE DOING AND WILL TRY TO-
HAS THE GOVERNOR SAYS MEET THE
MOMENT IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
REID. SO WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
AND SEE A DOCTOR JACKSON'S
CONNECTION HAS IMPROVED SO WE
CAN GO BACK AND HEAR HIS
TESTIMONY DR JACKSON ARE YOU
THERE. I AM HERE TO SOUND ANY
BETTER IT'S A LOT BETTER SO I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO ASK TO GO
BACK TO THE START OF YOUR
TESTIMONY SO WE CAN MAKE SURE
WE GET ALL OF THAT ON THE
RECORD AND I KNOW THERE'S GREAT
INSIGHT THAT I DIDN'T WANT TO
MISS. THANK YOU FOR. WORKING TO
OUR TECHNICAL PROBLEMS. AFFECTS
US SO THANK YOU SAID A GLAZER
SAID IRAQ FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY. MY NAME'S
JACOB JACKSON RESEARCH FELLOW
AT FTA SEE WHICH IS AN- PROFIT-
PARTISAN POLICY RESEARCH OR.
MICHAEL TODAY ABOUT A REASON
REPORT N. TAKING AND- ON TIME
THE- CAL. STATE AS YOU'VE SEEN
FROM THE EARLY TESTED. CSU IS
MAKING IMPRESSIVE. STRIDES
TOWARD ITS GRADUATION. OF GOLD
OF SEVENTY. SIX YEARS AND 40%
FOR YEARS. HOWEVER STILL FEWER
THAN A THIRD OF UNDERGRADUATES
FINISH YOUR DEGREE. REPORTER TO
GREET HIM FOUR YEARS. EACH
ACTUALLY. STUDENT A GRAD
CONGRESO. ACROSS NOT TUITION
BUT BOOKS. BE SPLITTING X.
WHICH CAN ADD THOUSANDS THE
COST OF A- AND LATER. STUDENT
AT. MOST OF THE- HOWEVER IS
OPPORTUNE. COST OF NOT. THE
WERE FORCE WERE CS USED. TO
CALL WELL. BACKUP THE RAMP
FIVE. DOLLARS FOR. BASED ON CSU
EARNINGS DAY. MORE-
HISTORICALLY. UNDER STUDENTS
OFTEN HEY THIS EXTRA COST. IS
THERE. GAPS FOR YOUR- RATES. BY
RACE. FAMILY AND PER GENERATION.
ONE TO CLOSE THESE OUTCOME GAPS
IN TO FOCUS GAP IN UPPER. AND
ARE POOR LOOK AT ONE OF THESE
EFFORT GAPS- THE ASPECT OF ON
TIME GREAT. COURSE TAKE EARLY.
IN A STUDENT'S CALL CAREER. ANY
AND ENCOURAGING STILL TAKE FULL
LOADS. HAVE BEEN A MAJOR OF THE-
INITIATIVE TO TWENTY FIVE AS AS
YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA. BROKE
IN OUR RESEARCH WE USED
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA FROM
THE CSU ENROLLMENT PASSWORDS
BUT ALL WE GOT. DAY FROM FOUR
K. VOLUNTEERED THEIR D.
IDENTIFIED LONGITUDINAL DATA.
AND SALES. THE MAIN FINDING
FROM THIS. FIRST MOST STUDENTS
DO NOT TAKE UP UNITS TO BE ON
TO GRADUATE FOUR EARS. OUR
FINANCIAL PURPOSES STUDENTS ARE
FULL TIME AT UNITS TO- BUT IT
TAKES AVERAGE OF FIFTEEN YEARS
TERM THIRTY PER YEAR. AFTER
GRADUATE TIME THE TYPICAL
STUDENT ROLLS IN ONLY ABOUT
THIRTEEN UNITS PARTNER. THE
MOST RECENT DATA WE HAVE SHOW
THAT AROUND 43% OF
UNDERGRADUATES ENROLLED FIFTEEN
UNITS WHICH IS UP FROM JUST
ABOUT A THIRD. FIVE YEARS AGO.
SECOND OUR STUDENTS ENROLLING
IN A FULL COURSE LOAD ARE MORE
LIKELY TO FINISH ON TIME.
CENTRAL FIFTEEN UNITS AND
THEY'RE JUST THEY'RE VERY FIRST
TERM ARE ABOUT ELEVEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS MORE LIKELY
ABOUT TWICE AS LIKELY TO FINISH
ON TIME. AND A LITTLE MORE
LIKELY TO GRADUATE IN SIX YEARS
AS WELL. AND THIS IS NOT JUST A
CASE OF MORE PREPARED STUDENTS
TAKING MORE UNITS AND THE MORE
LIKE THE GRADUATE ANYWAY. WE
WERE ABLE TO USE THE STUDENT
LEVEL LONGITUDINAL DATA FROM
THE CAMPUSES. TO DETERMINE THAT
THIS RELATIONSHIP EXISTS FOR.
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS FOR FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS FOR STUDENTS WITH
LOWER HIGH SCHOOL GPA SONORA
CITY SCORES. ADD TO THAT NO WE
FOUND SOME REALLY. A IT'S
ENOUGH TO PROMISING TRENDS OF
COURSE. IT'S A CALIFORNIA
PROMISED. AND A GRADUATION IN
TWENTY FIVE START. ALMOST EVERY.
HAS DRAMATICALLY INCREASED.
THERE WE GO HAS DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF
FRESHMEN TAKING FIFTEEN UNITS
ARE MORE IT IS ALSO ON PAGE
SIXTEEN OF THE REPORT- YOU CAN
SEE THE CSU'S TOTAL THERE- IN
IN KIND OF HATCHED ORANGE. ONLY
TWO CAMPUSES DIDN'T. WE'RE
ALREADY VERY HIGH IN THE THAT-
PERCENT PRESS TAKING FIFTEEN
MORE UNITS VERY FIRST ARE.
WELCOME TAKING INCREASED FOR
ALL STUDENTS MANY GAPS STILL
REMAIN BETWEEN GROUPS. AS YOU
CAN SEE ON PAGE NINETEEN THE
REPORT IN FALL OF 2019407% OF
WHITE STUDENTS ENROLLED FIFTEEN
OR MORE UNITS COMPARED 239% OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND FORTY PER
1% LATINOS. THERE'S ALSO AN
EIGHT POINT GAP BETWEEN FIRST
GENERATION STUDENT COLLEGES AND
APPEARS AND THERE'S A SIX POINT
GAP BETWEEN HEALTH GRANT
RECIPIENTS OF THEIR PEERS. THE
GOOD NEWS IS THAT EARLY COURSE
TAKING MOMENTUM. SEEMS TO HELP
ALL TYPES OF STUDENTS AND IT
SUGGESTS THAT CLOSING GAPS IN
OPPORTUNITY. COULD HELP CLOSE
THESE GAPS IN OUTCOMES THAT WE
SEE LATER ON. SO. WE SUGGEST
ENABLING AND FACILITATING MORE
STUDENTS TO ENROLL AND FULL
COURSE LOADS CAMPUSES ARE USING
THEIR CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM PLEDGES WHICH STUDENTS
RECEIVE PARTY REGISTRATION AND
OTHER BENEFITS FOR STAYING ON
TRACK TO GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS
SOME CAMPUSES ARE PRE ENROLLING
STUDENTS- INCOMING STUDENTS FOR
FIFTEEN UNITS MANY DOESN'T
REPORTED CHANGES IN HOW
STUDENTS ARE ADVISED. CAN'T
SHOULD ALSO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
INCREASE COURSE LOAD AMONGST
FROM THE STORE UNDERSERVED
GROUPS AND SUPPORT THEM EITHER
IN THE OURSES. THE STRATEGIES
MAYBE THAN THE ONE BEING
EMPLOYED CURRENTLY. WE ALSO
SUGGESTED CAMPUS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO MEET THESE INCREASED
RESTORE. AND IN. IN COURSE
TAKING. OUR STUDENTS OPTING FOR
LET'S SAY FIFTEEN YEARS SINCE
OF TWELVE STILL NO ONE BASED
THE SAME. BUT IT DOES MEAN THAT
THE CAMPUSES PROVIDE MORE
COURSES WITH NOBODY JEWISH
MONEY. IN RECENT YEARS CALL
JUST USED EDITION GRADUATE AND
ISSUE DOLLARS. INCREASED FOR
CORE. MISTAKE SATURDAY FUNDING
FOR MORE YOU KNOW STOPS THE
REVENUE FOR COLLEGE. OR
CULTURAL MORE STOOD. AND MORE
CLASSES. AND LASTLY THE
PANDEMIC A MAKING THESE EVEN
HARDER ADVISOR. ONLINE COURSES
CHANGES IN STUDENT MAJOR IN
FRONT. ARE THEY'VE ALL JEAN A
GREAT DEAL. IT'LL BE IMPORTANT
CONTINUE TO MONITOR. OR
STICKING SEE IF THE GREAT
STRIDES EARLY COURSE TAKING OUR-
AND WILL MONITOR THEM OF EARLY
TAKING AND OTHER CHANGES THE
CSU SUCH AS A LEARNING. ON ON
TIME. RATES ARE GRADUATE RATES
AND GET OF THE CS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DR JACKSON
I'M GLAD WE WERE ABLE TO CLEAR
UP THE- THE TECHNICAL ISSUES IN
HERE YOU'RE TERRIFIC TESTIMONY-
SO IT IS YOU. OBVIOUSLY HAVE
THIS FOCUS ON THE FULL THAT
TAKING THE FIFTEEN UNITS TAKING
IT EARLY. MAKING A BIG
DIFFERENCE- IRRESPECTIVE OF THE
OF WHERE THAT STUDENT COMES
FROM A BENEFITS THE UNDER
REPRESENTED IT BENEFITS
EVERYONE- BUT THE YOU KNOW THE
BAY. THAT THEY YOU'RE HERE FROM
THE CAMPUSES IS THAT- YOU KNOW
THE BOTTLENECKS COURSES THAT
THEY WANT TO TAKE THAT THEY
NEED AS A PREREQUISITE BUT BABY
ISN'T AVAILABLE. DO YOU HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS AT PERSPECTIVES
ABOUT HOW DO WE HOW DO WE BREAK
THAT DOWN. HOW DO WE HELP THE
CAMPUSES HAD A WE BREAK DOWN
THOSE BARRIERS SO THAT- THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE TAKING THE
FULL COURSE LOADS ARE ABLE TO
TAKE THE COURSES THAT THEY NEED
TO BE DONE ANY WORK ON THAT OR
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT THAT THAT
ISSUE. A COUPLE YEARS AGO WE
GET A REPORT ON GRADUATION THE
FIRST GRADUATION INITIATIVE
WHICH WAS AIMED. AT SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATES. AND WE FOUND
THAT- CAMPUSES WHERE TRYING TO
STREAMLINE THEIR DEGREE
PROGRAMS. SO THAT THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THOSE BOTTLENECK COURSES.
THAT WAS ONE OF ONE OF THEIR
STRATEGIES AND IT CONTINUES WE
WANT OTHER STRATEGIES- YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST A
FIFTEEN UNIT- BLANK CHECK IT TO
BE THE RIGHT FIFTEEN. AND IT
CONSIDER USING ANALYTICS FIGURE
THAT OUT A LOT OF CAMPUS WE
TALKED TO WERE OPTIMISED EVEN
IN THE FACE OF CODE THAT THEY
CAN GET. THE COURSES THE
STUDENTS- THAT THAT NEEDED THEM
THE RIGHT TO STUDENTS IN THE
THEM- A SO THEY'RE USING TECH.
THAT THAT IT TO GET PAST THIS.
BUT YES IT'S A MAJOR CAN THAT
THAT IS NOT JUST COURSES EVERY
BUT THE RIGHT COURSES ARE. IT'S
IT IN YOUR STUDY- AS- A SIMPLE.
POINT THAT NINE PER. IS IN
PERCENT OF THIS TO THAT ENTER.
HOPE TO GET AND FOR YEARS IS
THAT- DAY COME FOR EUROPE. I
COME FROM A SURVEY AND ASH
SURVEY. OF AND I EXPECT THAT.
CSU STUDENTS ARE MUCH- THERE'S
A THERE'S ANOTHER- I THINK
OVERSEE PER OF YOU SEE STUDENTS
EXPECTED SAME THING- WE DON'T
HAVE NUMBERS ON ON- YOU ON CSU
STUDENT EXPECTATION- BUT IT'S
SAFE TO SAY THAT. MORE STUDENTS
LIKELY EXPECTS TO GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS THAT DO GRADUATING
FOUR YEARS. AND SO WE HAVE
HEARD- A- IN SOME WAYS I GUESS
IT'S A REALITY CHECK- THAT THAT
THAT. IS STUDENTS WHO DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY THAT THEY'RE
TAKING OUT FINANCIALLY BUT THEY
THEY MAY NEED TO WORK- AND THAT
CREATES- THAT ADDITIONAL YOU
KNOW BERRIER THAT THEY HAVE TO
OVERCOME IN TERMS OF TAKING A
FULL LOAD. OF UNITS TO IT ANY
THAT DATA ABOUT THE DESIRE DO
YOU SEE ANY BREAKDOWN IN TERMS
OF THOSE- BASED ON. STUDENTS
WHO ARE WORKING IN THOSE WHO
ARE NOT. SO THAT DATA WAS
AVAILABLE AT IT'S REALLY A
REALLY INTERESTING QUESTION- I
THINK- AS EARLY- GIVEN EARLIER
TESTIMONY I THINK A COMEDY OF
MANY THINGS TO. ONE IS THAT THE
COURTS THE STUDENTS NEED ARE-
ONE IS THAT THAT I'M NOT COURSE
IS AVAILABLE AND ANOTHER IS-
THE BEST. I IT- STUDENTS BEING
AND- OR- HAVE TO WORK. I KNOW
BEING ABLE TO TAKE A FULL LOAD-
SURELY NOT ALL- WILL BE ABLE TO
ENROLL IN FULL COURSE BUT I
THINK. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE-
INCREASES IN THE PAST FOUR
YEARS- YOU CAN SEE THAT- IT'S
BEEN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
INCREASED AT ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE CAMPUS. SO THERE WAS
UNMET DEMANDS THERE THAT THAT
WAS EITHER CREATED OR OR OR- OR
WORKED AROUND EVEN FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE POTENTIALLY WORKING-
AND SO I THINK THAT THERE'S IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN AND EVEN
INCREASE. THOSE NUMBERS EITHER.
STILL NEED TO BE A FOCUS ON
THIS. THANK YOU ARE. REID THANK
BEFORE WE MOVE. I WANT TO MAKE
SURE INCLUDE YOU. FROM. YOU'RE
JUST ONE- YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
FACT THAT MOST OF YOU CAN. OKAY
IS NOW ONLINE FORCED. THE SCOPE
NINETY- ENDEMIC THAT THE US-
AND FRANK THE THAT ON MY AND-
MAY CONTAIN- ONCE WE RID TO
CAMP SAID YOU AT LEAST IN
PERILLO ON CARE SAID YOU. WHAT
IMPACT DO YOU. I BELIEVE THAT
THE ONLINE EDUCATION-
INITIATIVE WILL HAVE ON THESE
BOTTLENECKS COURSES AND THE
INABILITY TO OUR STUDENTS TO
GRADUATE WITHIN FOUR YEARS OR
FIVE YEARS OR IN SOME CASES. HI
THIS IS A GREAT QUESTION THANKS
SENTARA- SO. RESEARCH TAKES
AWHILE AND BUT WHEN WE STARTED
THIS REJECTION DURING MOST THE
TIME TO RESEARCH WAS DONE. WE
DO NOT KNOW THE CODE- WOULD
CHANGE THINGS QUITE A BIT- BUT
IF YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO TALK TO
SEVERAL CAMPUSES ABOUT THIS AND
ARE OPTIMISTIC THAT- ONLINE
COURSES COULD BE HELP IN
GETTING STUDENTS GRADUATE
SOONER THAN ESPECIALLY TYING UP
THE LAST QUESTION STUDENTS TO
WORK A LOT OF ONLINE COURSES
HAVE BECOME ASYNCHRONOUS
COURSES WHICH MEANS STUDENTS
CAN WORK ON THOSE BACKWARDS
WORK WHEN THEY- ARE ABLE TO
WORK ON IT SO THEY'RE NOT TIED
TO A CERTAIN TIME THAT MAYBE
DURING WORK HOURS- SO IT'S
POSSIBLE. THAT IF ONLINE
COURSES CONTINUE THIS COULD BE
ONE WAY- THAT- COMBINING IT
WITH OTHER THINGS- AND OTHER
SUPPORTS THAT CAMPUS COULD HELP
EASE THOSE BOTTLENECKS OR HELP
STUDENTS GET THE COURSES THEY
NEED WHEN. THEY NEED THEM.
ABSOLUTELY OTHER FOR TO THE- OF
A FUTURE REGION'S IN THIS AREA
THANK YOU MISS. AT YOU CENTER
ROT. DOT JACKSON THANK YOU THE
PA POLICY INSTITUTE IS A MAY.
READ TO ALL OF US- HAVE TO MAKE.
AND PUT POLICY BECAUSE YOU
PROVIDED. RESEARCH BATES- DAY.
OF A OF- RESULTS AND GOOD
PRACTICES AND WE SO APPRECIATE.
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE TO
DIG DEEPER INTO THIS
GRADUATION- TIME ISSUE WITH THE
CSU WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPORT WE THANK THE INSTITUTE
FOR THEIR- INVESTMENT IN THIS
TYPE OF VALUABLE- INFORMATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND FINALLY
A FROM THE STORE IMPACT CENTER
WE ARE EXCITED TO HAVE SIRI HOT
NAY EASIER. WHO SERVES AS A
DATA SCIENTIST AT THE IMPACT
CENTER WHERE SHE WORKS ON DATA
ANALYSIS VISUALIZATION AND
MODELING. SHE IS PASSIONATE
ABOUT USING DATA AS A TOOL TO
TELL STORIES THAT REACH A WIDER
AUDIENCE. PRIOR TO JOINING THE
SORENSON TEAM SHE WORKED AS A
DOCTOR IN INDIA. UPON MOVING TO
THE UNITED STATES YOU WORK FOR
THE UTAH AIDS FOUNDATION
FILLING VARIOUS ROLES THERE-
SHE GRADUATED FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF UTAH. WITHIN M.
S. INFORMATION SYSTEM SHE ALSO
HOLDS A MASTER'S IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND A BACHELORS IN
MEDICINE AND SURGERY FROM
INDIA. AND THAT'S A OF A
FASCINATING BACKGROUND TO- COME
IN HERE AND SHARE SOME
INSIGHTFUL THOUGHTS OF THAT.
OUR STUDENT COMMUNITY- THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN DOING A LOT OF WORK
AND SO WELCOME WE WELCOME YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU CENTERS
GAVE IT A ROUTE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION- LIKE YOU
MENTIONED I'M SHE'S AND I I'M A
MANAGER. IN SCIENCE OF THE
SEVEN SEVEN INTO THE- OF UTAH.
WE AN ACT APPLIED ACADEMIC DO
SO INSTALLED SOCIAL. THROUGH
THE USE OF AND INNOVATION. I'M
PROMOTED TO YOUR MCCARTY AND I
JUST HAS BEEN EXERTING THE
FUTURE DID YOU GET. STARTING
WITH PRODUCTION OF DEMO DRIVEN
INTO JUST CLOSER BUT HE SAID AS
LIKE THE LATE UNPAID. CHRIS
NEED TO DRAW AND OTHER REBUILT
ONE MARCH STOCK. THE OF HIGH
EDUCATION. BUT MORE ATTENTION
TO STATE AND THE- LEVEL DATA.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING OF
FOCUS NOT TO BE THE DATE BUT
ALSO THAT YOU CAN. THE STUDENTS.
WE HAVE SOUGHT TO MATTER ONE
TODAY AND- RECORDS AS CONTINUE
EXPLORE A CHANGE HOW DID YOU.
LAND LOOKS LIKE THIS TO AND BUT-
TO. SINCE TWENTY NINE WE HAVE
HELP MULTIPLE COULD BE AND KIND
RESEARCH EXPERTS FROM NON.
GOVERNMENT ACCREDITING BODIES
YOUR BEST. SINCE THE ONSET OF
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE
HAVE ALL FIFTY. THE I NEED TO
BE. WITH THE COALITION OF. AND
STUDENTS THE STATE. AND PRIVATE
POST INSTEAD. AND SOME THE
RESULT OF A VEHICLE SECOND
STUDENTS WE CAN. I'M NOT GONNA
SAY WITH WE CONSENT- WHAT ABOUT
TO THE MEDIA FINANCIAL. CDC
STUDY FOUND THAT ONE IN FOUR
YOUNG ADULTS AGED EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR DESCRIBED
CONSIDERING SUICIDE THIS SPRING.
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT IS
CRUCIAL DURING THESE TIMES TO
HELP STUDENTS SUCCEED IN THEIR
CLASSES. I'M FOR UNIVERSITY
CREATED AND USED TO DETERMINE
PROGRAM TO HELP SUPPORT TO.
THEY CONVERTED THEIR MENTAL
ENTITY HEALTH SERVICES COMPLETE
ONLINE DID YOU DID STUDENT.
GOOD MORNING THINGS ONLINE IS
NOT ALL THE NEXT SAID YOU. MANY
OF THE THAT CALL IN CAN DON'T
HAVE TO AN INTO CONNECTION. SO
THE SPRING SEMESTER INSTEAD OF
THE SYNC AND BE CONFERENCE
PICKED. ISN'T THAT KNOWLEDGE HE
CONDUCTED LEARNING TO AND MAIL
BASE PACKET. HOUSING HAS ALSO
BEEN ON THE MY YOU'D- MANY CAMP
HAVE THAT IS HALLS BECAUSE OF
CONFLICTS OF WITH OPENING
WITHIN THE CAMPUSES. ONE
SOLUTION BUT YOU OF. WEST
INDIES THREE WHOLE TO DENSIFIED
THAT IS INSTALLED. ABOUT 25% OF
THE FIRST YEAR STUDENTS WILL
LIVE IN THESE EACH OF WILL EACH
OF THE WILL OPEN IN THE SAME
WAY AS HOUSING- I WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION. EXAMPLE OF TECHNICAL
WE JUST OF OUR WORK GROUP TO
THE FACTOR. AT THIS TIME
PLEASE. WE HAVE A COMMUNITY
STRATEGY FOR SOCIAL ENGAGEMENT
THAT INCLUDES MUSIC COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. PARKING LOTS WITH WIFI
FOR STUDENTS WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION NINETY TWO TWELVE.
DRIVE BY CONTACT FREE PRINTER
SERVICES AND THEN THREE OF US
WERE HOUSING. THE COLLEGE TAKES
A WHOLE COME APPROACH TO SEVEN.
SO ACROSS THE HAVE ANXIETY ON
QUALITY EDUCATION THE JOB
MARKET COST AS WELL AS BASIC
NEEDS SUCH AS FOOD AND HOUSING
INSECURITY AND HOUSING
SECURITY. INSTITUTIONS THAT CAN
BEST SUPPORT THE STUDENTS AS
THEY NAVIGATE THESE
DIFFICULTIES ARE ALSO MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE BETTER STUDENT
OPENS. A GOOD STUDENT
EXPERIENCE IS STRONGLY
CORRELATED TO STUDENT SUCCESS
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THE
DISSATISFIED STUDENTS OFTEN ARE
PART OF THAT INSTITUTION
RESIDENTS ARE SATISFIED
COLLEGES THE HIGHER RETENTION
AND GRADUATION RATES LOWER LOAN
DEFAULT RATES. AND INCREASED
ALAMAT GIVING. BUT ALL STUDENTS
NOT CREATE EQUAL THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS. AND EXPAND
UPON UNIVERSITIES LISTEN TO
THEIR STUDENTS TO UNDERSTAND
THE DIVERSE NEEDS TO SUPPORT
THEM. EFFECTS OF COVERT
NINETEEN CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED
IT DOES PUT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF STRESS ON OUR STUDENTS AND
THEIR SUPPORT SYSTEMS INCLUDING
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
WE MUST INSIST THAT
INSTITUTIONS DO NOT FORGET THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF LISTENING TO
STUDENTS I TO COME UP WITH A
STUDENT CENTRIC EQUITABLE
SOLUTION TO BEST SUPPORT THE
JOURNEY TO COLLEGE AND
INTELLECTUALS. THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE
APPRECIATE THE- BROADER
PERSPECTIVE- THAT YEARS
RESEARCH HAS. BROUGHT TO
UNDERSTANDING HOW COLLEGES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE TRYING
TO. DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES I DO
NOTE THAT. YOU KNOW THE ISSUE
OF ONLINE DOT MENTAL HEALTH AND
THAT THAT THE ACCESS MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE IMPROVED THROUGH
THE- YOU KNOW THE- ZIP SERVICES
SUCH AS AMONG OTHERS WHERE THEY
CAN CONNECT MORE EASILY TO-
SOMEONE WHO CAN PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE- AB BUT AT THE SAME
TIME YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
HAVE SOME. THE TECHNOLOGICAL
CHALLENGES FOR ACCESS THAT
CREATES BARRIERS IN AND OUT IN
ITS OWN RIGHT- DO YOU SEE SOME
OF THE CHANGES THAT THE CO THAT
ENVIRONMENT HAS DONE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- THE- IT. YUP CHANGES
THAT MAY BE BUILT INTO THIS OUR
SYSTEMS ARE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS
GOING FORWARD ARE THERE. SOME
THINGS THAT- PUTS THE- EVEN IN
THE MIDST OF A PANDEMIC THAT
ARE ARE WORKING BETTER AND THAT
WE SHOULD NOT THROW OUT- AS WE
GET BACK TO WHAT WE HOPE WILL
BE A MORE NORMAL- ENROLLMENT
ENGAGEMENT WITH STUDENTS- YES.
CHRISTIAN AND THE- ANSWERS THAT
YOU GAVE I ACTUALLY. YEAH I
MEAN SO THE ACCESS TO INTERNET
BY THAT IS A PROBLEM FOR SHORT
FOR THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE
ACCESS IT'S DEFINITELY OPEN
AFFECTS ABILITY- AND- DOCTOR
JACKSON MENTIONED EARLIER THEY
TAKE IT NEEDS IF YOU'RE A
SYNCHRONOUS BOB YOU CAN WORK ON
YOUR CLASSES IT AFFECTED WITH
YOUR HOMEWORK I WAS ACTUALLY
TAKING CARE OF IT OR TAKING
CARE OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS- SO
THAT DEFINITELY DOES ADDRESS
SOME GAPS IN OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM- I ALSO THINK LAKE.
FLEXIBILITY THAT STUDENTS NOW
HAVE IN TERMS OF LIKE WHICH
CLASSES THEY TAKE I AM AND HOW
THE APPROACH THESE CLASSES I
THINK IN SOME WAYS IT'S MADE IT
EASIER FOR SURE SO I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THAT KIND. OF CONTENT
FORWARD IN OUR SYSTEM. THANK
YOU. CENTER ANYTHING ELSE BUT
WE THING THIS WITNESS FOR
TESTING. ONE QUESTION OF.
SEVERAL COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THAT YOU FOUND
THAT HAVE ROBUST- MEDICAL
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
WE WERE ABLE TO DETERMINE HOW
THOSE PROGRAMS- ARE FUNDED FOR
EXAMPLE DO ANY OF THOSE COLLEGE
ANY NEW COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES OFFER- OR PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE. TO STUDENTS. AT THE
FRONT OF YOUR QUESTION ACTUALLY
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT THAT ON SO I
WILL LOOK AT IT AS FAR AS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A DATABASE OF
ALL OF THE- ALL OF THE KIND OF
POLICIES THAT UNIVERSITIES ARE
pTOOK OVER IT. AND MAKE A VERY
ROBUST MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM
LIKE ONE OF THEM BUT FONG WAS
STANFORD BUT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO DIG INTO WHAT THEY'RE
HOW THEY'RE SUPPORTING THAT BUT
I WILL LOOK INTO THATAND I CAN
SEND YOU THE INFORMATION
ACTUALLY. THE REASON I ASK THE
QUESTION IS I BROUGHT THIS UP A
COUPLE TIMES IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. OVERSIGHT YOU KNOW
YOU UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HAS A HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM
THAT THEY AFFORD. ACTUALLY
REQUIRES TO ENROLL IN OF THE
STUDENTS STILL OTHERWISE HAVE.
VIRTUALLY SAYS MY
UNDERSTANDING. THE ISSUE DOES
NOT AND I'M I'M WONDERING IF
THE SYSTEM IS LARGEST SEE
ISSUE- WITH THE BUYING POWER
THE SYSTEM HAS COULD NEGOTIATE
WITH THE HEALTH CARE. INSURERS
TO. AT LEAST OFFER. INSURANCE
PROGRAMS TO STUDENTS THAT
INCLUDE MENTAL HEALTH COVERAGE
AT SOME LEVEL SO I DO HAVE AN
INTEREST IN IT AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO-
DURING YOUR FURTHER RESEARCH TO
COME UP WITH SOME FURTHER DATA
I'D BE. INTERESTED IN AND- AND
RECEIVING IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE TESTIMONY. THERE
THANK THANK YOU SENATOR ROCK.
MISS IN A YEAR THANK YOU FOR
THAT AGAIN THE WORK THAT YOU
ARE DOING WE WOULD WELCOME ANY
ADDITIONAL- RESEARCH DATA THAT
YOU CAN PROVIDE TO OUR
COMMITTEE AS WE- WORK TOGETHER
TO- TO IMPROVE AND TO DO. TO DO
BEST BY OUR STUDENTS WHICH IS
TO OUR MUTUAL GOAL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC- OPEN. LISTENING TO OUR-
OUR HEARING TODAY I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I PROVIDE THEM WITH
ANY OPPORTUNITY THEY WISH TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TO US- I
WANNA FIRST INVITE ANYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY. ON HERE- THE GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE THERE THAT IS-
REMOTE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY I DON'T SEE
ANYONE. LET ME ASK THE- THE
MODERATOR WHO IS MONITORING THE
PHONE LINES WITH THAT THERE IS
ANYONE THAT AS- I INDICATED
LIKE TO PROVIDE TEST MIGHT YOU
COULD. YOU COULD ASK THEM NOW.
I HAVE NO LINE. OKAY LET ME
GIVE ONE LAST MOMENT TO. SEE IF
ANYONE WANTS TO CALL AND TO
PROVIDE THAT TESTIMONY WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO HEAR IT. AND
WE ARE ALSO AVAILABLE TO
RECEIVE ANY KIND OF WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. AT THE CONCLUSION OF
OUR HEARING. OPERATOR ANY
CHANGES THERE. I HAVE NO
COMMENTS OVER THE PHONE AT THE
TIME OKAY. LET ME- LET ME WRAP
UP AND SAY FIRST THANK YOU TO
OUR MY WONDERFUL STAFF. SUCKS
YOU WHAT WELL YEAH AND STEVE
HARMAN AND OTHERS WHO THAT THE
TECHNICAL STAFF HERE THAT HAVE
HELPED MAKE THIS HEARING
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU TO SENATOR
ROTH FOR ALL YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
EDUCATION AND CERTAINLY IN
HIGHER EDUCATION- IF YOU ARE A
LEADER THAT I. CONTINUE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO FOLLOWING- AS WE
WORK TOGETHER TO. IMPROVE OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND ENSURE
THAT IT HAS THE RESOURCES IT
NEEDS TO- TO THRIVE- I
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
TODAY- I'M I'M APPRECIATIVE OF
EVERYONE- WHO WAS BROUGHT THE
IMPORTANT. INSIGHT AND DATA TO
THE TABLE I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE
ARE PULLING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- WE KNOW IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS TO.
ACHIEVE THEIR THEIR ALL THEIR
GOALS AND FOR MANY IT'S
GRADUATING IN FOUR YEARS. HOW
THEY CAN SAVE MONEY AND TO THE
WORK FORCE SOONER IN THEIR
CHOSEN FIELD AND INSPIRE. OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS TO DO THE SAME.
ONE OF THE MOST INSPIRING-
FACTS THAT WE HEAR EVERY YEAR
YEAH IN THIS CASE- OVER A
HUNDRED NINETY NINE THOUSAND
BACCALAUREATE DEGREES WERE
AWARDED BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY- THIS PAST YEAR. AND
OVER 50% WERE FIRST IN THEIR
FAMILY TO GRADUATE WHAT AN
AMAZING. AN AMAZING LADDER OF
ECONOMIC. SUCCESS HAS BEEN
PROVIDED BY OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS THAT SO
INSPIRING AND SO. AS WE ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS CAN CAN ACHIEVE
THAT THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION
IT SENDS A MESSAGE TO THEIR
BROTHERS AND THEIR SISTERS-
AND- ALLOWS THOSE FAMILIES TO
HAVE- THEIR DREAMS THAT.
ACTUALLY CREATED AND FULFILLED-
GOING FORWARD- AND WE KNOW FROM
THE TESTIMONY WE HEARD TODAY
THAT- THAT THE LONGER STUDENTS
STAYS IN. SCHOOL THE LESS
LIKELY THEY ARE TO GRADUATE.
AND IF THEY CAN STILL OFF
STRONG AND TAKE THOSE FIFTEEN
UNITS AT THE BEGINNING THAT IT
INCREASES THEIR LIKELIHOOD OF
SUCCESS SO MUCH. MORE SO IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO INSURE
STUDENTS CAN MAKE PROGRESS.
TOWARDS A DEGREE- THAT THAT DAY
IN SOME WAYS WE'RE TRYING TO
SHIFT BACK TO- THE TRADITIONAL
FOR YOUR MODEL IT BECAME A
LITTLE. COMFORTABLE FOR PEOPLE
TO SAY WELL SIX YEARS IS OKAY
OR MORE- BUT WE KNOW AS WE HEAR
FROM THE SURVEY DATA THAT
STUDENTS WANT TO GET THROUGH
AND FOR THAT TRADITIONAL MODEL
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO. RE
ESTABLISH AND- MAKE IT BE THE
NORM AGAIN- AS I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING. TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS THAT THE
SYSTEM HAS SET. 40% GRADUATION
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS THAT
INCOMING CLASS IN LESS THAN
TWELVE MONTHS THAT'S GOING TO
DETERMINE OUR SUCCESS IN THAT
REGARD. SO A LOT OF GOOD
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE WE'RE
SEEING A LOT OF GOOD PROGRESS-
IN TERMS OF THE- GRADUATION TO
GET CLOSER TO THAT NUMBER- BUT
WE DON'T HAVE TOO MUCH TIME
LEFT TO. TO DO ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO DO. TO MAKE
THAT GOAL ACHIEVABLE- AND SO.
FOR THAT REASON I KNOW BY
COLLEAGUES AND I ARE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING TO- AT PARTNER-
WITH THE SYSTEM WITH THE
FACULTY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATORS- WITH THE
CHANCELLOR AND IT IS WONDERFUL
TEAM. TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT- WE CAN MAKE THAT
GOAL A REALITY AND HAVE BEEN
BEEN VERY SHORT TIME. SO WITH
THAT I THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE STUDENTS
SELECT COMMITTEE. ON STUDENT
SUCCESS. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONTINUED WORK TOGETHER- IN
THE COMING YEAR. AND WITH THAT-
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.